it is June 21st and we are off the rails
cheers
we are we are so off the rails today
love you
thank you everyone okay
oh my God what happened are you coughing
for real oh really wait what now I was
screaming too hard and I but Dan started
like just coughing super loud right into
them
oh you muted yeah yeah well done you
okay um I just I just I was screaming
off the rails baby you want some water
today's episode no I got some
I got some
say it oh today's episode is sponsored
by Gamers
let's go
soothe the throat hit that hold on show
Dan hitting that oh yeah
suck that titty boy cheers my dude
cheers my dude today is our last
episode in the studio
before our summer break because Friday I
hope you're all tuning in at 8 00 P.M
Pacific time because we are going to be
doing our live show it is so exciting as
so excited
it is gonna be a banger show there's
going to be surprises there's gonna be
laughs there's gonna be just a whole
slew of good times to be had cheers
tears potentially tears Cheers Cheers my
dude cheers my dude I hadn't planned on
tears I'll be totally honest I don't I'm
just thinking over the show we planned I
don't think there's gonna be tears maybe
tears of laughter
gut busting tears of laughter
but anyway I look forward to seeing you
guys all there also if you guys coming
are watching we are going to be doing
the same thing
with the TF sample sale stuff so
um
it would be cash only there you go but
there will be an ATM there unlike the
last time yes yeah yeah right yes yeah
but uh it's gonna be basically free
because we just have a ton of like
samples that we get and
you know a lot of fashion companies they
do uh Sample Sales
and um we just have it just accumulates
it's just so much stuff so we're
basically giving away at like cost or
below cost for you guys to just pick up
and it's fun to do it at the shows
because it's all the best all the best
folks out there you know what I mean
so there that is
cheers my dude also we are doing an
event that requires your guys's
participation we're doing a segment
um the link is where are we putting the
link on Twitter
yep it's up okay so there there's a
survey
uh with a few questions it should be fun
they're fun questions you just write in
your answer and the answers will be used
in a segment on Friday so if you guys
could please go over to Twitter
click the link and just the survey takes
like two minutes it's literally just
writing sure yeah hey love Could you
actually also post it on the Reddit and
maybe pin it there yeah sure for people
that don't use Twitter yeah I got you
thank you you can do it real real fast
and easy and it's fun it's going to be a
ton of fun
so yeah very excited uh also you know
what occurred to me yesterday we had
this Teddy fresh event which was very
fun it was very uh successful a good
time
it was a
I was like damn dude I mean it was very
crowded and I was like oh this is
perfect timing for me to catch Cove oh
don't say that but we were all there or
many of us were there great it is though
I was like okay this is where I catch
covid like and then I'll be sick the day
of the show again
I'm in the doghouse because of that
event
with who
with my girlfriend the hecking dog why
because I didn't go and I didn't mention
it to her and then she saw all the
pictures she's like why the didn't
you tell me about that yeah we wanted to
hang out it's fine you did you you do a
lot you don't want to go see us on the
goddamn evenings well I wouldn't put it
that way but why didn't you tell her
about it
uh well I had kind of forgotten about it
until Ela mentioned it on Sunday and it
just I don't know it just kind of
slipped my mind it was just I didn't
intentionally not tell her about it but
I just did it on now I'm in trouble did
she believe you yeah I mean I'm being
facetious she's not like that man but
not in the doghouse not on the couch I
will be allowed to sleep in the beds you
guys are I hope okay all right Dan is in
live show very forgiving I mean oh yeah
during the day it's go time it's go time
now Dan is Big Time involved in
everything live he's he's he is
Wizarding it up
everyone was looking amazing oh yeah and
Frankie Jonas
uh did a few songs it was very nice it
was a really nice event
Breaky Jonas is the
uh youngest I don't know how many how
many of them are there is there four
Jonas Brothers so he's the other one
there are three in the Jonas Brothers
Band so they made a band and they're
like not you
I don't know if they said that
he's a baby all the brothers looking
let's go and make a band not you well
how young was he he's a lot young how
old was Michael Jackson when the Jackson
Five he was like four years old right he
was younger so wait Frankie's Frankie's
22. how old is how old are the other
ones
if he wasn't tap dancing I don't want it
right that's what I feel about it
you 22. you now he's a great guy
and really talented he was he was doing
good it wasn't it wasn't oh here we have
a video of it oh he posted it cool
it was a hard act bro I was like because
it
it was really cool but I was my heart
was going out to him because it's super
awkward just to promote just to perform
and then there's like a semi-circle of
people and then there was a lot of
people behind there who weren't even
paying attention because I don't know
they're at an event they're drinking and
schmoozing and I was like boy this is a
tough act but he did good he did really
good
don't claim me bro oh
did you mean it I did yeah
let's take a look at this performance
don't claim me bro
he's a cool guy looks like Bob Dylan too
which is kind of cool
is that an insult I think Bob Dylan's
handsome
I mean he's okay
when he was uh he was a little cutie
patootie when he was young
cutie patootie well he was kind of like
a twink a little bit Bob Dylan twink era
I Googled 24 or maybe don't show that
because that's oh yeah uh Bob Dylan in
like
1964-ish I would say okay so Frankie is
22 and his Bros are 30 33 and 35. big
difference man
there you go he looks just like him 35
you
I love Bob Dylan
strange guy especially in his older days
he's very odd but I'm a big fan as well
me too I mean how can you not be
this is crazy good
but um yep good times ran into all kinds
of great people there and I had a lot of
fun
enjoyed seeing all you guys there Sam
crushed it oh my God
Sam brought our
world famous teddy bear wall to the
event we're famous
she added plush it was so do we have a
picture of that
yeah it was it was so nice and people
were really
taking because it you put it there so
people take a photo of it and people
were really it's an art people were in
yeah we're in line it's really really
beautiful that was that was dope
uh but people kept I guess trying to
lean back on it but it was like really
really
not stable and so people would touch it
and Sam was there sweating because the
Wall's like Yay she was she was guarding
the wall all day
yeah you were there or you were there
Ian you saw what was happening yeah she
was on Red Alert with that bear wall he
was holding it down yeah she was working
hard on that so oh here's some here's
some photos
here's the lovely couple
um
yeah that was awesome
you guys are looking good A B put on a
spray tan for the event and you looked
really good
did you really not yeah I don't think so
you haven't asked me the same thing when
you walked away she's like did he get a
spray tan and I was like I'm pretty
positive he was complaining about a
sunburn so that's the only reason
I asked he got when did you get so much
sun though on Sunday Sunday look at this
look at my chest dude yeah that looks
bad not his breakdance what were you
doing what'd you do on Sunday uh just at
the pool did I I actually I put my alarm
on my phone and my phone overheated and
turned off so no alarm went off and I
kind of dozed off by the pool
um do you remember I was like you're
gonna be golden in like two days and you
were like that does not happen to me
looks like you got a spray tan beautiful
careful with the sun man I'm telling you
my dad just he's getting like skin
cancer like every week not like serious
but either where they have to like
treat it and stuff SPF is literally so
yeah are you not sunscreen gang I am
usually yeah did you sunscreen that time
no this time I did it I did
listen wasn't good enough if Robert
Kenny Kennedy Jr was here I would say if
you're worried about 5G
that sun is like a hundred G that
will you up
oh yeah the sun is the Real Enemy
damn
here's Frankie and his uh girlfriend but
um
yeah it looks great welcome to Sam so I
think it's visually working on probably
something for Friday it's not here right
now
yes sir good times yeah let's see what
we have for the show today uh xqc came
after me in the funniest way possible
and he up because he was talking
oh on the day before off the
rails
and he came to me with the weakest
you could ever dream of so I
will be coming after xqc
um
yeah I'm gonna spend his ass like a coin
and put his put him give him for
a spin dude
oh that's right
about to win a jack pack on your ass
dumbass jackpot
a jackpot for the crackpot
Bing
Bing what's your grand prize you
also in other news
uh we're gonna talk about the Titanic
everybody's captivated by this missing
submarine that went down to the Titanic
also we are going to be talking about
Olivia is present okay where are we
caved we're doing the Colleen Ballinger
PowerPoint it's just gotten to it's come
too far yes and at this point there's
nothing
that's it we didn't do anything we're
just talking yes we're just covering
what's been said we also don't touch on
what we're not supposed to touch on
Trisha Paytas
right correct that's not in my
PowerPoint today good yeah I wouldn't
want you to have Trisha Paytas in your
PowerPoint who are not supposed to talk
about
we talk about what's going on with the
environment can you talk about other
things
right now
is there any I mean is there anything
about climate change yeah PowerPoint
today because otherwise you're just
wasting it I wonder maybe there is maybe
he's talking about like the ozone local
and economic State and like a DM or
something microplastics any mentioned a
microplines they're forever chemicals
any sort of torque reform in terms of
like history I think microplastics
picked up like a little bit a few years
later I think that we're we're a little
and Colleen we're in the beginning of
microplastics with the Colleen Ballinger
fandom you know I would love to actually
have
um Jaden Smith I would like to hear his
thoughts let's get him on I I one I
genuinely Wonder it's like okay let's
talk about the geopolitical state of the
world yeah tell me
give me your order to comprehend you're
gonna have to break some
huge comprehend in order to comprehend
and to eat the uh the the omelet of
knowledge you're gonna need to break
those actions that's so funny yeah they
didn't cut that
also announcing our brand you know we
said the back the bachelor is over I do
not want
to deal with that anymore but the back
lure
is in have we met yeah we talked about
the bathroom and we've got lots of
submissions for Dan's new chair today we
are proud to announce 16 finalists
Dan is going to be controlling the
bracket as we work our way down to the
eventual winner
and Dan have you looked over these
options yet I haven't I looked at the
honorable mentions which we have an
album of honorable mentions and some
pretty funny stuff in there that didn't
quite make the cut but um no Ian was the
one who uh made the selections he is my
matchmaker my back maker and uh I will
be seeing them for the first time today
I gotta say based on what I saw in the
subreddit not a lot of options I think
you're gonna like really okay well
it is what it is but you gotta pick one
I mean and you've got an area more
comfortable than the Scorpion chair
right they're probably on all
they're all more comfortable I mean
gotta be right well in the honorable
mentions there was like a spiked torture
chair right a bicycle seat
um on a stick yes so hopefully the
hopefully the worst stuff was just in
the honorable mention category well
we'll see that's all very exciting stuff
coming up
I saw a post on the subreddit and I just
wanted to give a shout out real quick at
the top
to a fan who was just diagnosed with
cancer you know
I gotta yeah my heart goes out
he says
so I've been watching history all my
life hypnosed with cancer LOL is the I
get the vibe though like I get it
that's kind of how I felt on Monday
right
and I haven't heard back from my
hematologist so
I feel like that's probably good news
he's still waiting I guess on some test
results that haven't come in okay
gonna say if it's really bad they'll
like kind of be in a hurry to tell you
right I yeah but he he's still waiting
for them it was your white blood cell
count you were mainly concerned with
correct white and white no the white
blood cell wasn't that bad it was the
the platelets and the um
the titler got it it was the titler
and the did you by the way did your
the tri-paste and the titler
the Tedder Anna titter
by the way this person has cancer and
I'm making it all about me it's pretty
awesome did your family member get back
to you Lena
all right is she not there yeah he did
but he mentioned my Twitter
because
let me get my phone are you just gonna
say that
what do you say about that he replied
but he said
let me tell you I'll just send you the
screenshots it's not good is it it's not
good or bad it's he said it just framed
it very scary but no it's not no
oh because I said you're not gonna like
it he said it's basically inconclusive
it depends heavily on the clinical
context a lot of people have positive
anas and are perfectly normal and some
providers don't even order them because
there are so many false positives
and what about the titter
he didn't mention anything specifically
about that
[Music]
um
what is the titter if that in most cases
I'm just kidding it's Anna tighter oh
okay gotcha
but yeah he said it depends heavily on
like why they're even testing for it and
it's a test that's only helpful if it's
negative because it can rule out a
diagnosis
okay that's the tri-paste try taste try
taste try tip
ditch which one was that about
that was about the
let me check the message I sent him
previously yeah a dude with cancer we'll
get back to you in a second okay you got
it you know
it's yeah it's the tighter one okay
tighter the Anna tighter yeah
yeah they mention the tribe Chase
okay whatever it's fine I talked to all
my doctors about it
but anyway the point is I'm gonna read
it because I want to send love to this
person I've been watching H3 all my life
and found out uh found this channel to
actually lift me out of many depressive
episodes
that being said and I don't even know
why I'm wasting my little life come on I
have left on Reddit to post my feelings
it didn't take you that long to write
this
right
uh but anyways I'm just typing words as
I'm thinking them Cancer Sucks my
grandma then my mom and now me are gonna
probably die from it and honestly it's
funny hearing jokes about it see
and it takes away from the everyday
nature of think about dying God I love
you H3 fam no homo no homo and I hope
the podcast no homo I hope the podcast
lives on for many years after I'm gone
well I don't know what your situation is
but uh we love you
and um if there's a chance to beat it I
hope you uh do
you go and if there isn't cheers my dude
love ya Oklahoma actually the comments
are super funny baby sorry about
your cancer and then the other
one is just no that's real estate
dude you guys are demons it's so funny
where'd you guys get that from I
wouldn't joke about that
I like Norm's take on cancer I'm pretty
sure that when you die the cancer dies
at the exact time so it's not a losing
battle to draw
that's a really good plant
oh I miss him yeah he's a good one man
you know but uh hey
the feeling is mutual so
you know
the
the man
it's
yeah that's bro
life is dumb yeah
dude life is like so dumb
life's low-key kind of lame
hmm
all right let's talk about xqc this
dumbass is this it is just one video
this is the one okay well they were like
battling all day apparently I I I didn't
watch much of it I just saw this clip in
like one other why it like
while arguing I wanna
Hassan when he comes back this man
is in Japan
sitting in his Airbnb arguing with this
dumbass like what are you doing dude go
have fun
who cares I mean we've had this exact
conversation so many times it's like
dude dude dude
relationship yes scumbag he always comes
crawling back
oh yeah and then Pokey I guess is now
trending because she was like I wouldn't
sell my morals out for a ton of money I
don't get that and everyone's like whoa
look at her woman
on Twitter right now
wait because she said she wouldn't sell
out to kick yes she said I wouldn't
basically I wouldn't sell at the kick
that's woman Behavior people like look
at her look at her get your balls off my
face man I would sell out the kick for
100 million
oh I just opened Twitter in the top post
Pokemon is a bully
people are need to move on man
what a bully time to move on from the
Pokey
was why is she a bully there's no
further information I don't know it's
just doesn't happen I open Twitter he's
the top top tweet I know Pokemon is a
bully period no further details she's
not a bully right love
nope nope no she's the best
he said it he said it
anyway listen to this try to come
after me
top streamer on Twitch or well I guess
he's still on Twitch
uh the front part is missing from this
but
it took I guess we'll we'll understand
it as Hassan does yeah
and have you ever been talking about me
though have you ever done
Ethan Ethan is literally the least bald
on the planet what are you
talking about he's like famous
so apparent I think what happened was he
saw my Twitter profile picture
uh he was calling me bald I I wish I
could get
the first part of this I sent a screen
cap of it where he uh shows his picture
of Europe no he did not pull this
picture up this is my new profile
picture on Twitter
he pulled that up yeah I sent it in
Discord
oh my God you're glowing
he just called me bald at least didn't
call me fat
he did or just right now yeah okay calm
down fog
still hurts but
so that's the first awesome moment there
we love
um
are you mistaking him for someone else
his hairline is literally like down to
his eyebrows
I don't give a he has a white hair
the man is a 60.
wait okay that's a different okay so
that's the difference I see he he came
prepared for this uh debate give a
he's like 60.
I mean
um so I don't know I don't know what
Ethan did I don't know what you're
talking about what is it he he did like
a loot box or something what I'm pretty
sure chat give me give me the give me
the files on that dude are you gonna
come on here and accuse me of gambling
or some and then be like oh yeah
chat told me that two minutes ago like
the bro
this is the best offense you have for
being a scumbag is oh Ethan did a loot
Buck I think according to chat
wow
wow dude that's cool sure
sure I'm pretty sure I I actually last
time but it's wait did you just
say
mobile some that I didn't even know
about you called them bald and and then
you're saying I don't even know what the
you're talking about
I mean right same it's all I mean
perfect response it's like what the
oh bro bro bro bro
I'm just saying it's because you use
them as an example because he's he's not
clean on that you can't be serious
crypto gambling he thinks you did crypto
gambling I don't think he knows
I don't think he knows yeah I think he
read in chat somebody said
and I'll explain that in a moment but I
don't want to watch this I'm like
gambling then I think it's it's
up that he did that
um good thing he's not doing it any
longer I think I don't know
oh I like that look at that you can
put money it opens up some chess what is
he looking at Ethan is that your boy oh
is that him oh you're comparing all
sorts of like chess Brothers this and
that to the worst of the worst I don't
know why you think what do you mean
wrong you bring it okay and have you
talked about it it's like you don't care
because it's your friend but you think
that you can't back in the days
he's referring to the ball rider I I was
still mad at me for ball Riders but
there's no it was a freedom of gambling
it was a free to play mobile game uh-huh
that people got super mad at me for
because we were like on a super long
Hiatus and this game was in the works
for a while and it came out before I
returned so we put out this game ad and
people were like the you've been
gone and now you're dropping a a game
you're selling out it was a whole thing
it was actually a disaster the game lost
money uh it was a whole game it
was it was a disaster honestly it was it
was horrible and then they removed the
game from the app store because it was
just a nightmare
uh but uh
here this link I sent is time stamped
where you're at it's just a better oh
this is better one yeah let's watch this
then
um
but it's a free-to-play game it had loot
crates
I'm pretty sure I don't even remember
it's been so long but I'm pretty sure
that Loot Crate was just cosmetic
it's okay it's the loot crates yeah
because that's being a right because
that's how you got there was new
cosmetic items okay and loot crates are
are exploitative I I it's
like I see where he thought he had a
point there but the gulf between that
and unregulated crypto gambling from
like some Caribbean island is listen
pretty wide this is a game I put out
like five years ago
okay it was a free to play game that we
all lost money on could you resell the
Skins no you could not resell the Skins
there was no aftermarket it was just a
stupid mobile game so his point
is Hassan why haven't you talked at
Great Lengths with your best friend
Ethan about the mobile game he put out
five years ago where you could get
crates to get cosmetics in a free game
that's been off the app store for four
and a half years
wow great on man you're the
dumbass who's come on
come on your stream and said I what I
did was wrong I regret it nobody should
do it and then you came back and said no
that I want to get paid like nice
try dumbass
holy
like what do you mean that's bad
this is this is what it looked like I I
Curb Your H3 oh some it's a
it looks like a a hater of it Curb Your
h3h3
loot box
owned you got owned by this video yeah
apparently you made me defend this dude
yo Ethan did this and so therefore I'm
entitled to take 100 million dollars
from kick the gamble all day
it's like you don't care because it's
your friend but you think that you can't
like it is because it was no I have
never talked about it because I had no
idea this is stunning feeling
stunning why the would I
it's a mobile game loot box from
four years ago how the am I
supposed to know every single thing that
this man has done he's also said the
n-word with a hard R okay Hassan
that Mr 911
yeah and you want to bring anything else
up there that that luck I cracked up I
was like great thanks bro
okay Mr friend then crenshaw's
eye hole
and he very openly has apologized
multiple it's like bringing that
up and being like whoa no he's
right he he he has a point that's he's
right it's what they always do that's
right that's right
yay again it's fine I'm not hiding I I
the one thing I can do about this whole
thing is the n-word things never hiding
from it and always embracing
that what I did was wrong and
apologizing for it and I just I
appreciate every time Hassan brings it
up it's the n-word it's great for me you
know what the N word is remember when he
said that everywhere the hard R but
that's really up that you're
working with him it's like yeah I know
that well I know that and he's addressed
it and then that would like bringing up
jolt coin from shrimp way back
when I didn't do a coin that's
still not even the same no I think yeah
right right
who was the crypto rug poll yeah who was
that he's like yo I did stick up
a bank at gunpoint but Ethan did a he
had cosmetic loot boxes in a game five
years ago that was free to play maybe
some of flip a coin
who was that I think it was trained
that's right right train wreck did the
jolt coin thing okay
got it
they don't do the synthetic Behavior
right bro I don't even know what the
jolt coin is either it's like some
that misky brought up about train
no but like xuc just talk about what
you're doing
like let's stop talking about train
wreck and Ethan like just ex talk about
what you're doing and justify it in a
way that isn't like oh you well you're
not you're not criticizing everybody
else that's not
that's not a defense man that's what
about ISM oh
uh okay so okay so now it's valid the
one's not bad
Holy Spirit
okay I wasn't saying your your train
washed or you're trained posting
beforehand I was saying your arguments
resemble trains now I'm saying it you're
train wash brother who the
talked about joltcoin or misgive or any
number of things now I'm saying it
you're you are schizo
no we don't say that we don't we we uh
see Hassan you up
um we do not disparage
the mentally uh impaired uh uh
neurodivergent yes
neurodivergence it's a serious illness
we don't use that as an insult
and I'm gonna bring that up every
goddamn time I talk about you
or whatever the goddamn
bro you're fighting Shadows
you're fighting demons in your head
right now what the what are you
talking about I'm just saying I mean
your focus shifts based on who is doing
it and I think that's that's inherently
bad obviously it's a good thing I don't
think that's true
you're right I think I should go back
same issues were brought to him or me no
matter who's doing it we would be
against it maybe it would only come to I
mean what you really need to do in this
situation now that I'm a debate Lord
or a debate uh how does his son refer to
them
debate the
pervert perverts yeah
[Music]
you got a nail him down he used this to
distract from the point and he did it
successfully in the fact that nobody
nailed him down on what a dumb analogy
it is you got to say okay do you think
a loot box and a mobile game five years
ago that was free to play and just
Cosmetics is the same
as taking a hundred million dollars from
a crypto gambling casino
two
with and this is their intention is to
get your audience to go and gamble on
their website is that the same thing
right that would have been good in
Hassan's defense though like he said he
doesn't even
know what the he's talking about
I'm not I'm not I'm not even criticizing
it's just like i s it's just you're
right though so stupid yeah
no his son's doing great
I mean he's standing up for me that's
all I can ask
cheers my dude could have gone without
the heart ER thing but
love you we love you
okay there it is good job Zach to our
attention because someone as large and
prominent as you is doing it but that
doesn't make it personal or different
for different people
okay dude
is he stunlocked but then the other
thing is um right there he pulled up the
photo ah dude you're back I thought this
was the real photo of me I mean he's
seen me he's talked to me before
I guess hey you never know with Ethan
things change Ethan I mean
yeah this is what he looks like now it's
been rough
the other argument is like let's not
even compare let's say you're right
let's say Ethan did this loot box thing
and it's horrible okay and I'm gonna
talk to him about it let's just assume
that
let's talk about what you're doing and
not compare it to what other people are
doing
thank you
owned
thank you undefeated
no he he realized but he's pulling it up
and he's trying to see if it's Photoshop
that he did that
um good thing he's not doing it any
longer I think I don't know
oh I like that look at that you can
put money in it opens up some chess oh
wait I went back too far Ethan was that
you're working with him it's like yeah I
know that well I know that and he's
addressed it and then that would like
bringing up Julia right really you're
Trump saying God damn it I went back too
far
I didn't go back so far what the
happened okay here it is it mean brother
look at him squinting at it people do
but that ain't me
it's not what he looks like
dumbass I mean he's on copium
it's my goddamn profile page your
audience actually believe that that's so
funny okay
um
I truly had no idea I'm sure if I were
to ask him uh he might have addressed it
he might not have a problem with it yeah
it's like one of the worst things that
ever happened a Streetball writer like
one of the worst chapters of my whole
life not because of the Loot Crate
just because it was such a disaster and
everybody hated me
you know what I mean these are all
things oh yeah and I did one draftking
ad like must have been like six years
ago we did one draftking ad for
fantasy football
on the podcast yeah we did one draftking
ad a long time ago and the thing was it
was for a fantasy a fantasy football
league I didn't know or I had clarified
is this Sports gambling or is this just
fantasy and I think they I was under the
impression with just fantasy we did one
ad with them and never worked with them
again and that was like five years ago
fantasies
you don't remember that DraftKings no it
sounds familiar DraftKings H3 it must
have been in like the first year of the
show or something right is this it wait
some episode came up
no it was before way before this
oh no oh this is okay so this is from
three years ago
thank you to DraftKings for sponsoring
Us in 20 in 2020 yeah three years ago
thought it was a little older but yeah
we worked with DraftKings one time so
so I owned sports are we worked with
them one time and then we I mean no I
don't want to do this yeah and even then
again it's like
DraftKings is Incorporated in the United
States is it's you know they're
regulated as yeah which
you know it's not lots of people think
it's still bad but it's okay it is not
on the same level as uh office crypto
gamma I'm not I'm against promoting
gambling to kids okay but here's the I
mean listen so sure you can point to
this to me like ah Ethan's a hypocrite
giraffe King is you can't go on
draftking if you're not 21. this
cryptofucking steak.com literally an
eight-year-old can go gamble on that
with crypto it's insane but you
know what okay I worked with draftking
one time three years ago you're right
finally back in particular football oh
maybe I shouldn't play it giving them a
free ad yeah no
yeah
so there it is uh yeah exactly so that
that's the um next
[Music]
but again I'm not currently doing it
so there's a big difference yeah no
speak on because I was unfamiliar with
this until you just brought it up
because I don't know why you think it's
an own overall because you brought
ethanize some sort of like sword or
something like that like like no because
no I didn't Ethan is irrelevant in this
conversation I brought him up because to
say you me train wrecks and Ethan Klein
had this argument about crypto
gambling literally years before yeah
ever joined The Fray before miskip ever
got in the conversation that was just to
show you that the timeline in your head
is wrong that I have been consistently
speaking out against this sort of thing
way before uh Mischief ever joined
that's the only reason why I brought up
Ethan to the conversation
yeah yeah I I just wish that I just wish
that um see no there was two combos
before Miz before uh Miss give God I
think it was when what a dumbass anyway
that's it
you're so desperate to
justify it just be honest with yourself
you're doing a scumbag move for a fat
paycheck
just own it you know what I mean it's
not like oh Ethan the draftking three
years ago I then decide made the
conscious decision not to work with them
anymore
owned what a dumbass you guys really
team xqc now I Know Abe met him once so
he fan so Abe has like that's all it
takes for me yeah he's like yo
XTC is my boy dog oh yeah amaranth's
party right that's amron's party yeah
and then he almost came to my gym once
with amaranth almost man wow almost but
uh but no obviously I was just doing it
for the meme what do you mean almost
what happened uh he was supposed to come
and I was like having a back and forth
with amaranth about him coming into the
gym and finally uh I got them to agree
and then he just didn't show up the next
day
I think he was up late streaming so you
are talking to XU through xqc through
amaranth you're trying to encourage him
to come no no amaranth was already
coming and she asked me the night before
if he could come oh I see yeah
so close man
damn well yeah I obviously was just
going along to me
I don't know anything about him besides
what we've done on the show oh I think
the sound bites though
yeah anyway what a dumbass so let's
thank our sponsor real fast gamer sup
who we love love love love love love
love love
and we'll move on to uh all the other
great stuff probably even potentially
doing next the PowerPoint hmm you know
it's time
yeah but uh thank you to gamersop look
at this stuff man I love their new pup
Gamers suck you beautiful bastards my
dude cheers
yep I love gaming stuff
[Music]
I'm don't drink sugary drinks
you know listen my brother-in-law if he
and he does watch the show but I'm
talking to you he's trying to lose
weight
uh-huh and he's over my house
on Sunday for Father's Day and he's
sitting there drinking a full
sugar Dr Pepper what I was like bro what
are you doing
Gamers up man
it's hydrating it has no sugar
it gives you that boost of caffeine
you're looking for and it tastes great
and it's good it is going to help you
lose weight if you're drinking sugary
drinks cut that out
seriously
come on now
yeah but uh it's still okay listen this
is the last time to try gamer subs for
free
before our new flavor drops later this
summer
oh mama spicy Margarita is that the name
we settled on for it
our flavor
oh yeah it's Sigma Sigma all different
flavors okay whatever
what are they gonna do
but well that flavor is not available
but their classic ones are like I I mess
with the black cherry I hear great
things about the Pina Colada the mango
I've heard great things about blue Razor
Blues come on get real that's what it is
cheers my dude get your rizz up with
blue Raz
check this out though for free you can
get it for free
oh they're doing the free one you
guys oh no oh no you guys listen to this
this is crazy when they do this
gamersupps.gg okay use the code H3
and you get free shipping
and a free sample for the next 48 hours
do you hear me it costs you nothing
if you missed the 48 hour window you can
still use code H3
uh at checkout look at this to get 10
off
dude free GG sample dear row and knows
it's no you don't have to pay for
shipping
it's literally zero
you just put in your shipping address
we've lost their minds it's insane
so that's it guys go to
gamersup.gg use the code H3
get free shipping and a free sample for
the next 48 hours God bless them I love
gamer what's up and thank you for
sponsoring us and thank you for
supporting our sponsors
[Music]
up
oh my God this post blew my mind
okay this blue
tell me what you think about this
is there something going on with Ethan's
basement
I remember Ethan said on the show that
Alfredo refuses to go in the basement
that's still true one day alfredo
stop going in the basement he will not
spend any time there he used to come
down with us used to love being down
there with us one day
he refuses he will not go and if you
carry him down he runs right back up he
will not be down there hmm
I just I it's so odd right I even asked
the vet
my parents dog is going through this and
I remember we were trying to figure it
out we couldn't he just one day stopped
going past a certain spot on the stairs
yeah we can't go to my parents room
anymore and he it's been like three
years yeah why it's so confusing he's
good on the stairs it's not a stairs
thing he goes up and down stairs no
problem I don't know
we were like maybe he tripped and fell
and doesn't want to go back maybe uh I
don't know but the old thing is it's an
interesting idea so listen to this is it
possible that there's something
unhealthy in the basement that Alfredo
can smell
for example quick Google search says
that mole can cause kidney problems
along with other issues dogs can smell a
certain type of mold it would explain
why Shredder is experiencing health
problems but not Alfredo also Ethan's
been been in the basement a lot and has
weird blood tests
was that
is it windy outside I feel like our roof
is that big truck going by or something
uh people have pointed out mold
poisoning can indeed trigger an immune
response however I'm not a doctor
um wait hold on you're not a doctor oh
delete the post ban them from yourself
well so this blew my mind and not so
there was an issue because the
basement's underground when it was
raining a lot that some of the wall one
wall in particular I know was getting
saturated with water from the house
but if you look at the wall there's no
visible mold
but it would be inside
so
and also another thing is that there's a
mechanical room down there with all of
our uh water heater and AC furnaces and
stuff yeah and so I don't know if
potentially it could be fumes leaking
out of there too is also a potential
um
but I gotta after I read this throughout
after I read this
I went downstairs last night and I was
like I can't be here
and so we're calling we're having a mold
guy come today right Lena uh she just
walked away with you I heard her on the
phone no she's right here I'm looking
yeah yeah I'm here he is coming today
no results until later Friday probably
can we expedite that
if they do it through a lab I'll ask if
that's an option
labs
expedited it's two days from now
yeah
what am I gonna do
that's right my Diablo 4 is down there
right it seems like a pretty good
turnaround in my opinion 48 hours I
would like if he could test you right
now drop everything and go test it
so I'm getting I'm testing the mold and
I don't know if there's a way to test
for a harmful like fumes from the
from the mechanical room Lena do we have
any leads on on that no I'm not sure I
mean do any of you guys know
who we could because the mold guide
doesn't do that he said it's just
specifically mold right that makes sense
as far as like something leaking in
there yeah it's like a boiler room or
like hot water or whatever hot water
furnace for them I mean I would check
for like uh carbon monoxide but that
wouldn't cause the immune response yeah
I would just kill you yeah you just um
perfect well what we could do you know
sometimes if you call the city Lena and
you suspect there's a gas leak they'll
come and check it okay I don't know if
that I don't want to abuse that yeah
uh service do you that's only the gas
company though and a gas leak you would
smell because they put salt so when you
go inside it smells a little of gas oh
it does smell a little of gas but I
don't know because there's so much going
on in there yeah you should be smelling
it at all but the door's closed if you
call the gas company you say you smell
gas they'll be there almost
instantaneously
they can expedite it I don't know who
yeah can we expedite that can we get
faster also maybe we'll call uh some
Ghostbusters too while we're at it yeah
get everything looked at skip
you want me to call Linda yeah right
well I don't know that was the other
leading theory is that there's an evil
spirit down there it could be but I
gotta say I haven't seen any evidence of
evil spirits down there The Vibes are
pretty good you listen to any Credence
down there at all no not even Klein
water once all right well we'll be uh we
can cross that one off radon gas
oh radon isn't that on like super old I
don't think maybe they are I think
those heaters are pretty old 15 15 years
is that it was radon used 15 years ago
is that when the house was built yeah
that's
um no I don't I don't think radon's like
50 year olds yeah
maybe we should call the city because
there you do smell of gas down there you
if in that case you should call your gas
cup well hold on someone say you can get
a detector from Lowe's but so I have a
carbon monoxide detector okay but that's
not the one we're worried about I don't
think you could smell that
also cut yeah you can't smell yeah no
that doesn't smell like anything but if
it's if it's natural gas and you smell
that and you said you smell a little
yeah when you go inside it smells it
smells of gas I think you got to get
that checked out
so what if they're the mold guys like
dude there's deadly mold and then the
gas likes gas guy's like dude you are
leaking this is hazardous it's just like
a conversion of all up just
everything but I was down there last
night and the air it just I was sitting
there and the air didn't feel right boy
and there's no circulation down there
there's no windows there's no
circulation yeah yeah no that's true
radon has been used since 1990.
[Music]
yeah the house was built in 95 I believe
or no it was built in 2005. 15. you
we just made somebody have one of those
oh my God I'm old moments 2005 I know
that didn't sound that long ago does it
that was 18 years ago yeah
radon comes from the ground so how do we
check for Radon
everyone's saying radon comes from the
ground how do I check for Radon
how to check for Radon
uh this is right on test right on test
kits can be purchased at hardware stores
let's go let's open the laboratory oldie
I want to check
I want to check radon
radon
[Music]
um
let's call the city
and let's get some radon testing kits
you know what I mean let's get in there
and uh
so oh yeah and we're getting an air
purifier right
yes
when do we get the larger one um I'm
gonna Check reviews and stuff first
because I would be comfortable being
down there if we had an air purifier
until you know
lead detection you guys think I'm just
breathing lead
there's no shot is built in 2005.
Elena can you look at can you maybe pick
up um they're called Geiger counters
they detect oh great you're sitting on
like uh yeah I I will I don't know that
big machine room it
I don't know what any of those things do
could be some sort of small okay so
people are saying Geiger counters okay
let's get one of those it get a
geiger counter I'm gonna be like it's
like Linda ghost hunting yeah yeah oh
can um if you could look up probably
find one on eBay uh Xbox Connect
check for ghosts
right
you know what I'm talking about right
shovola or some something something
there's no asbestos I guarantee it it
was 2005. you don't you cannot use
asbestos
oh Cheyenne says I have an air purifier
in every room okay Cheyenne I didn't
know about that Luke maybe we should get
my Cheyenne we should be getting 10 of
them
I think you can too I need industrial
air purifiers in every goddamn room and
a big ass Crystal the biggest one we
could find of shungite
[Applause]
I do not trust
yeah it's a joke
also someone said you can get an
inspector to check for everything
a home inspector yeah he can check for
all that yeah I think don't they a
b when we got our house they checked for
all of that except the ghost yeah I
believe so I mean I assume you had an
inspection done when you bought the
house right our house was built in 1920
so yeah oh your house yeah they're like
yeah you got this little raid on you got
a little asbestos
because the lead holy God our
country's
they gotta fix the pipes yeah can't
drink the water
what do you brush your teeth with you
brush your teeth with tap yeah just
don't drink it I saw my brother drinking
it when we visited last time but
don't do that man you do not want lead
in your body of the year
all right so so I'll keep you guys
updated but that that was a genius post
I mean I didn't even occur to me
I mean
I'm desperate for any answer so
yeah we can call a home inspector let's
get everybody in the Ghostbusters every
all the king's horses All the
King's Men to fix my Humpty Dumpty ass
I'm on it I want also that
the witches that you didn't get burned I
want witches and omelets of knowledge
this is where we talk about burning the
witch yeah hear me you know the era
where we used to burn the witch right
yeah that area never really can you get
a priest in there to do an exorcism
that'd be awesome
do I stop at a priest let's get a let's
get a shack and a rabbi oh let's get it
how do you call it a shack A Shack yeah
a rabbi and a priest walk into my
basement walk into Ethan's basement yeah
oh there's an evil presence down here
my doctor did mention High what white
blood cell count could be uh from
Paranormal uh hauntings he did
can cause a rise in the Anna tighter if
I mention that first
I used to watch murder porn
[Music]
so thank you to to the poster
cheers my dude and uh I'm at avac Tech
your HVAC contractor should be competent
enough to find a leak in your furnace
yeah so I doubt there is right
um
the system seems to be in good condition
and stuff but I'm just trying to think
of
just trying to think of anything you
know
well and the the Alfredo thing remains
such a crazy mystery why won't he go
down there
there's no leaking I feel like this is a
good lead this totally makes sense yeah
he's got a sensitive nose and he's just
like that well and I feel this
down there Shredder is like
the sweetest most loyal loving dog yeah
to me and Ila right
and he would go down there with us even
if he smelled it
it makes sense yeah Alfredo he's he's
from the streets he's too smart for that
exactly I love you guys but uh I'll be
up here
wow so here who who wrote this I want to
thank you for this electronic sector
four one six thank you shout out
electronic sector 1416. no homo love you
yes homo full homo get over I want to
kiss you on the lips love you
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay my basement
does not look like this you can stop
sending these
next week's uh see you next Tuesday
I just peed in my basement
wait we just found out the quartering is
six six how did we find that out uh I
found out yesterday talking with some
friends at dinner that recently one of
them saw him in person and yeah he's the
quartering is Harley told me whatever
hardly good Epic Meal times he's and
Harley's really tall
he's like an actual real life ogre
I mean I'm tired I'm sweaty that's
awesome I'm overweight
he Shrek
I was thinking more like the warcraft
ogres but yeah Shrek works too you get
that crotch rot more like this kind of
guy
like this yeah
yeah
okay quartering six six
I recently learned that the quartering
is a uh
low IQ inbred loose there's a little IQ
inbred Loser yeah we knew that about him
so anyway we're moving on uh also just a
little Tim pool thing for you guys I'm
gonna hit you with this oh no I need the
original link or do we have Oh shoot no
um Circle back to it okay I have to grab
that this morning but all of it so at
this point should we talk about the
we have two big segments but maybe we do
one of them and then we break it up with
the uh submarine talk and then do the
other
let's do Olivia PowerPoint okay people
want to know about Colleen
and then after Colleen
we'll do the The Bachelor
did we argue about the bat chairler did
we haven't had that uh discussion on air
yet no okay so some people think that it
should be called the bat chairler
which theoretically
you know on paper it's better because it
fits right into Bachelor almost
seamlessly the problem is it sounds dumb
try to say it but chairler back chiller
yeah
I don't know if that's a strong argument
because I feel like the other name is
also extremely difficult to say backlar
the back Chiller no back the backlar
see I don't think you're saying it right
it's the back Chiller no
that's the pronunciation the backlar
look it up well backfire doesn't make
any sense doesn't sound like the
original one
it's better it's easier to say it rolls
off the tongue The Bachelor
that's insane if you're gonna say oh
you're gonna watch The Bachelor tonight
like what language are you speaking
but Chandler
I don't know can do a poll I guess I'm
about to
I like backlar personally
back
here we go oh somebody said
quartering is training now Ethan respect
the fellow men on the Journey of weight
loss I didn't know that and of course I
I'm
I love that for him I love that forever
yeah I didn't know that good for him
poor
um interesting ogre is a state of mind
in his case uh oh you guys like the BET
trailer okay they like the chair I don't
I don't love it but it's the people have
spoken the chairler why don't you take a
seat right over there
I don't know about that one
okay well we'll do that
so we'll do Olivia we'll do the back
trailer and then we'll talk about the
sub
so with all that being said Olivia all
right
actually what's up what's going on one
thing I want to do real fast I'm just
gonna go use the bathroom okay no
problem I have a bunch of super chats
that I would like to read at so I'll do
that right now let's see
uh happy summer Everyone by the way I
don't think we mentioned that today's
the first day of summer
uh
Let's see we got one here from Tam I've
been a member for like 220 years now Dan
I deserve a shout out oh Olivia I love
you so much does IQ iconic cute girl
wave thing you were already doing it
Olivia you knew
uh here I'm just gonna try and hit the
bigger ones first so we'll get to it
uh Daniela it's uh my 21st on Monday I
put proof in Discord if you're feeling
extra generous Zach I would love the
passport song uh too long but go ahead
and give her the uh
you know 21. he didn't verify yet
she said she had proof I know okay
that's I mean send it to Zach you have
to send you can't just post anything
you it's messy just have it it's
okay Alyssa uh
donate ten dollars that's uh six years
ago when I lived in Germany my neighbor
joyfully said no homo after my
brother-in-law forgot what country he
was in and gave him a double
double cheek kiss when they met no homo
right the vibe's a little different in
Europe
um
Mr Clean said no pressure Ethan but if I
don't laugh this whole episode I'm
ending it all tonight with a picture of
you and Dan in my arms Jesus dude that's
intense don't do that
never commit suicide
uh Tangled headphones so Dan what are
your thoughts on Petro Dragonic
apocalypse oh oh that's the new gizzard
album right did that come out today I I
like the singles that were coming out of
it um no but you know it came out last
week though
I have an idea what you're gonna say go
ahead Zach Lewis debut record love songs
and what have you yeah
on Spotify Apple music YouTube you name
it very proud of it worked very hard on
it Lewis appreciate it y'all give it a
listen uh let's see I'm gonna try and
hit some more big ones uh
20 donation from Alex I was literally on
the red Disneyland when the live show
ticket dropped and due to bad service I
wasn't able to get tickets damn I'm
sorry hope everyone has fun though love
you guys no homo okay uh thanks Alex
my vacation yeah we ruined your vacation
dude those Rich luck sound bites are so
addiction pretty good like me and I are
driving over the weekend I'll just say
it he's jealous of me and Dan ruin my
home
standing
Dan is jealous of me it's so good uh Ari
donated 20 bucks and said hi it's my
last day being 21 can you drop a sound
bite for me please proof is on the
subreddit okay it's okay because we
didn't say it till now but from now on
the proof needs to be sent wait but why
wouldn't they want a 22.
if the last day of being 21. hit him
with the 22 you're right yeah like I
feel like that makes more sense yeah
yeah let's hit you with the 22. 22.
that was so weird
uh Jesus says it's my 26th birthday on
Tuesday can I get a shout out from the
pocket oh my God Jesus turns 26.
I thought he's a lot older all right hit
him with the 26. you there you go
from now on though proof proof required
uh another 20 here
uh from squid my brother Matt
is it a 21 it's 31. okay I can do that
okay uh 31. you all right all right
Matt congrats on 31. that's a big one
that's a real important one
um uh I posted a copy of his social
security card birth certificate and
passport in the Discord oh I didn't
realize okay now there's leaking
information a little far guys uh I don't
know JJ said y'all should look into
Pearl's old reaction videos with bangers
such as whitest girl Reacts To Love Sosa
okay she refers herself as whitest girl
that's a problem
[Music]
pull that up yeah we can look into that
yeah
yeah we might have to play with it a
little bit just copyright I'll help you
see
no
oh it's she's reacting to a song yeah
Chief Keef
um real quick the devil donated 20 bucks
and said Hassan is giving passport bro
energy with this vid what is what's a
passport bro I don't know that I have a
new theory is the devil just Kevin that
dude uh
I think it's Kevin
because I haven't heard from Kevin then
I was rehabbing right here
comments by the way let me see when the
last Kevin
here we go passport bro is men traveling
to find a wife I think
Uh Kevin last Kevin siding was June 16th
and the devil appeared
on
later that same episode June 16th there
it is Yo no one can know it
you might be honest I don't think this
but just to play Devil's at advocate for
a second Kevin I got your ass uh
the password Bros are men who choose to
seek out foreign women typically in
other countries for their relationships
I see that's like 90 Day Fiance that's a
very nice thing to say I don't I don't
think that that's Hassan's Vibe I got it
but maybe
wait why does this show xqc what is this
just a YouTuber it shows that it's xqc
he looks you know I've seen that error
uh pop up for me recently as well where
it when you go to a video and it's
showing the last video's Channel
so all kinds of great stuff going on
over at YouTube I'm certain like
I said it kind of as a joke but
unironically ever since Susan left 100
the product is kind of falling apart no
I I truly believe that Susan is she was
holding that place together she was she
was I I don't know what's going on all
of a sudden I'm trying to tell them to
report a bug and they're saying I'm
lying
all right let's move on uh Olivia oh
Olivia let's get into
The Forbidden PowerPoint we've been
putting it off putting it off but we've
come to the boiling point we can ignore
it no longer this is Colleen Ballinger
and it this is lots of twists and turns
this is the timeline really this is long
and this is not just drama this is
really crazy Dynamics really crazy
relationships
I mean you said it takes a bunch of
twists oh it works good no he was on the
journey with me
um but yes it's it's pretty crazy
the devil says you'll find out in about
43 years surrounded by your friends and
family so if he's giving me another 43
years oh that's pretty good that means
I'll I'll perish around 80. yeah 80
because I'm about to turn 37 just or
despite what you try to connect
me up you just like lie wait is that
right am I 37 see I'm confused now 37.
you're 37 for a few more days decline
age oh
wait I'm 37 now 42. 43
oh I mean within yeah you're 42.
wait I'm gonna turn 38. Canon says
you're 42.
38 38. you I don't like that 38
almost sounds like 40. so that's like 37
was sounding better
37 is like
38 is like you're what's up guys
all good
nice to see you
that's Waleed
repeat
not wallyp oh
cause I can't no more can you play that
uh the the pearly's doing
oh Old Town Road Old Town Road
I'll help you save till I came home
I'll help you save till I can no more we
got the printers in the back scanners
are attached you can't even fax I can
help you no more meter reads no more
hidden fees just me with me and you will
see
there was a Fri so she was making it
sound like she was commissioned to do
this and
um oh my God that's her right yeah I
thought it was me where did I see this
but apparently one of her bosses was
like you need to stop wasting your time
doing this that nobody wants really
I where did I see that I know what
you're talking about maybe it's ready
[Music]
no it seemed credible I just don't I
don't freaking remember I remember I
think it was a post where someone showed
a clip of her talking about her old boss
it was her talking about it I believe
her boss told her to stop working on
that
using our one right yeah she's a great
employee
she knows a lot about Corporate America
all right well anyway uh as much as we
love to talk about our wonderful Pearl
uh and she is one she is a beautiful
pearl
well let's talk about so you were saying
it's more than T yes the Colleen it's
like decades long
very complicated very confusing
dynamics that we haven't really seen
before because content creators online
are a new situation and the way in which
they're able to communicate with their
fans is very different than it's ever
been are we talking about potential
crimes
I'm not gonna ledge you don't know
crimes or anything yeah I'll take you
through what we know and we'll talk
about it all right let me open the
PowerPoint let's just here we go
[Music]
this is it we've been building up folks
Cheers Cheers by the way she has
[Music]
disappeared since this started right
yeah that Trisha the Bugatti Patricia is
there's no word from it they should stop
vlogging
we have not gotten this pretty heavy
duty well here it is so let's let's
figure out what's going on here yes this
one's kind of long oh I'm here
that's what I love oh let's go I'm here
for the long power points okay
Colleen Ballinger yikes okay
um powerful strike okay so this is
Colleen Ballinger she's a YouTuber today
she is 36 years old
next guys
um a character she portrays is Miranda
Sings
um you may recognize her she's pretty
popular she was towards like
2012 I think 2013 was her like Heyday
what's the darling Miranda yeah Colleen
was the darling yeah yeah I mean her
whole Persona she was like
remember that year where like Jake Paul
and Logan Paul were like in all YouTube
marketing and everything 2017 2018. that
was her yeah she was on Jimmy Fallon I
believe well yeah because you'll see
when we we get to it but she had a like
a Netflix special she had a Netflix show
she did a Broadway show didn't she she
uh we're gonna get to that because I
have my own personal experiences okay so
you've got it's all here and then on top
of it you used to be a huge fan yeah we
talk about that's all in here there's
anybody I've given all of my time to
like if we had to figure it out it would
probably be Colleen because 2014 to
2020. I just like watched her content so
you are in a unique position to
tell us about her you know everything
about her
um right in terms of like
morals this is a crazy crazy thing just
because how much I used to love her and
how much I disagree with everything
she's doing the picture you shared with
me is that in this the picture the one
because you wrote the thing for her oh
yes yes yes don't you worry don't you
worry all right so let's just go ahead
there's all the biggest fan okay so this
is Corey this is her best friend who
lives with her and her husband and her
kids he has lived with her for a at
least five years and um
he is always at her side that is
extraordinarily bizarre why would a
grown ass man
36 want to live with
a woman his friend and her family her
kids she's lived with her
well she was in a relationship before
yeah she was married and um then they
divorced and Corey and Colleen lived
together
and then as we got to know more about
Colleen's life and how she met someone
new blah blah blah
um Corey just stayed he just like has a
room he he lives there what if I'm
assuming he's single right Corey yeah I
think you're dating people see him on
like dating apps and stuff like how you
gonna how are you gonna live with
a baby what the three are you doing both
of them it's so weird yeah it's it's
yeah does he work that's like not yes
he's her assistant and um he edits her
vlogs
whoa that's okay
um this is Adam Adam McIntyre he is a
YouTuber yes he's in chat what's up oh
yeah hey
um Adam please let us know if there's
anything that I forget to mention don't
mention we would love to hear from you
um
so back to Adam McIntyre he's a YouTuber
who does drama
um videos and he
Rose
to fame summer or spring 2020 and we'll
get to it and it's in the it's in the
PowerPoint alrighty
this is Cody Rance
another person in this Saga
um they
we're always of age they participated in
group chats and they came out with a
video that was the Catalyst to this new
this new wave of yeah the new wave of
okay
okay this is the weenies group chat
which is the the group chat that Colleen
was in with young fans
um I think Adam said that there was a
total of 23 people in the group chat um
mainly 13 to 17 year olds so Colleen had
a group chat that she was very active in
with a bunch of her fans and her fans
are young they're like 13. yeah I went
to 17. when I see this stuff it's like I
would have really killed to be in a
group chat was it like a text group chat
or was it like yeah you'll I there's so
many uh screenshots and stuff so how are
these people selected to be in her I
think it was prominent people on Twitter
so like Adam was really really active in
her live chats and on Twitter he would
at her a bunch and I think that's just
you would she was looking for something
or funny yeah she was looking for loyal
people loyalty they've all turned on her
by the way or I think I don't know if
all did all of them turn on her pretty
much oh
woof
yeah Adam says 23 members including
Jessica and Colleen Jessica is Colleen's
sister-in-law
um
no no no like whoa no no no Colleen and
and Jessica were the
were the adults in the group chat okay
okay yes so this so what is this okay so
these are the Ballinger kits
um in the middle that's Rachel cooling's
sister on the right that's Chris
Ballinger
um their older brother he is the husband
of Jessica they have a family channel
where they film their kids oh they also
have a family challenge if you um
remember actually a few years ago do you
remember when YouTube was turning off
comments yeah
um a big reason was uh people were time
stamping in their comments because one
of their sons does gymnastics and um God
yes and I do remember watching Colleen's
Vlogs and she talked about it and she
said basically like it's such a shame
that YouTube is turning off the comments
and like these people are ruining it for
us and it was just like a very
interesting outlook on the thing with
children on video and I remember when
that was a thing there was like straight
up pedos time stamping yeah and little
boys and girls videos that they just put
up for like their family and friends and
stuff yeah and then these videos people
like hundreds of thousands of views and
time stamps to one like they're in a
compromising position it's so so so so
so so so vile and disturbing I felt like
YouTube disabling the comments it was
either that or like bandcamp content it
was so bad it was so gross
so they were they were pretty upset
about it when it was happening in the
opposite sense that the rest of the
world really was that is so interesting
yeah
they were the victims not the kids right
that's what's her what's the other
family Channel's name curious to look
the Ballinger Family and then on the
left um another important figure in this
that's Trent Ballinger their other
brother
okay they have a channel called the
Ballinger Family or did they are they
Famous by association yes did they
existence I think that they Rose to fame
due to like being in proximity to
Colleen and Miranda Sings but they did
gain their own audience and they're a
pretty big Channel let's see they have
uh two million Subs seems like the views
have dipped a bit I bet they were on
doing crazy numbers like uh five years
ago seems like they get about 50 000 per
let's see Pop
we have four years ago they got uh 34
million
20 million 18 million yeah those that
was with the family Vlog days man those
were the days
crazy okay yes
all right and then we can speed through
the the rest of the people this is um
Colleen's husband Eric Stockland he's
not really in this but if we mention
Eric that is her current husband okay
and then um this is Joshua Evans her
ex-husband
um if we mention Joshua this is Joshua
okay
so Colleen had a lot of success over
this past decade
she did a Netflix show that she co-wrote
Co
made with her brother Chris called
haters back off it had two seasons
um they filmed in Canada and Colleen
still says it's the best time of her
life that's where she met her husband he
was her love interest oh he was an actor
he is an actor and okay he was on that
show with her interesting yeah and so
was she married did she cheat on her on
her husband how did that work
it is
um speculated uh he certainly alludes to
it she denies it adamantly you'll see in
like some screenshots with children
she's talking about it
she clearly cheated on him I mean I
remember when it was all happening and I
felt very icky you didn't like it I was
I was very confused because she shares
so much of her life
with literally everybody oh my God Dan
our just crashed
we're getting the backup battery the
battery backup everything crashed
is the stream live still
okay
so bear with us
uh
oh can they still see it and hear us I
think yeah hi guys
yeah in a bad spot too don't go back to
her give us a sec we'll we'll resolve
this this happens sometimes
I guess we're we're just pulling too
much power is that what that means
Colleen's in the shoes
is there a way to
Dan is currently on the battery
AV is running frantically getting
extension cables
Dan was in the kitchen by the way that's
why I shouted for him
yes we've got buttons clicking ab's got
a fat AB was in motion fast boy he got a
faster well done a b
quick quick
[Music]
Dan you want to give me some updates to
communicate
he's working on it he says
nice sound it makes
you know
yeah I think Colleen is desperate to uh
stop the show
but she will not stop the show right
also
at the end you'll see the media storm
that's happening I think it's going to
get even worse for her there's more to
come yeah what
based on the some of the weenies uh
tweets oh oh my God
the weenies was that the name of the
chat yes
like her little weenies
collini weenies uh bear with us here
guys
[Music]
and we are we are plugging we are
unplugging we are beeping it's a whole
most it's a flurry of commotion here on
the on the podcast
I'm telling you guys there's just too
much going on
for reals is there do we need to upgrade
our
power utility or something Dan
potentially
I think it's a ghost
follow me from the basement
[Music]
oh I think we're good thank you guys
well done everybody
so quick the way we haven't started is
literally crazy the amount of info
you're about to get dude I'm so excited
this has been a long time coming in
yeah this whole story is really I've
also I've just like needed someone to
talk to about it also
um you've been going through a lot I
mean like
honestly in my mind there's a bit
of ventilation is this comparable to
like Shane's or like how would you have
worse it feels worse just because she
was so emotionally dependent on these
children
and I think that it really works it
seems to have really messed with them
wow because she didn't realize I don't
think she understands she was uh
homeschooled and she grew up very
religious and sheltered and
um yes the other kids are homeschooled
too by the way
oh and she was talking about possibly
homeschooling her kid that explains a
lot I think that it's possible
she
thinks of children as like she thought
of them as just friends and she didn't
when it first started she didn't maybe
see how inappropriate it was and then
they just were her friends
the whole schooling thing does
in my experience can mess kids up I
think to Colleen it was like these are a
bunch of uh fun little things on my
screen and I think to these kids it was
like
my idol is recognizing me and that was
their entire life
so are we good Dan are we
okay
we're just uh everything's coming back
thank you guys well done to the team
Dan's going to check the breakers
we will not be
but this is like the first hot day of
the year Dan is it related to like the
power grid
okay yeah it's the first like warm day
so I think everyone's blasting their AC
though I doubt it's
I doubt it's uh our fault
the breakers are fine Dan says
well why don't we continue if they can
see and uh
[Applause]
so so we're on success over the past
decade is that where we were yeah yeah
right here so she has her Netflix
special she went on Jimmy Fallon a bunch
for both seasons she went on she has
comedy special and she went on uh
uh Comedians and Cars Getting Coffee
with Jerry Seinfeld yeah and I've talked
about that at length because before I
even had an opinion about
her or her character I as a fan of that
show and that is the worst episode I I
mean that genuinely because the whole
point of the show is that the guest
drops their guard and they connect as
comedians as real people but she went
there in character yeah and she would
not drop the character the whole time
and it was just not funny so painful to
watch interesting I mean you have the
opportunity to sit with Jerry Seinfeld
for a whole day and you're gonna go be a
silly character well apparently
he liked her so much he brought her to
Jimmy Fallon that night
it was the night that she wasn't
supposed to be there he brought her to
play a game with him Bailey was taken
with her he must have been I don't know
here's my theory he has a daughter
that's like your age oh so he he saw his
daughter in her no he was doing it for
her oh he's trying to be the coldest fan
yeah for sure he wanted to do it for her
for sure
well done guys okay so and then also the
haters back off had two seasons so it
was relatively successful although it
got canceled in the end right it did get
canceled um it had like Angela from The
Office was one of the leads it
it was a well-produced show it was fun
did it was good and we're talking about
this more I assume the show about how
she met her a husband I'm curious about
that we can talk about it um because so
what happened was she's married to this
guy so okay she went I'm gonna take you
on a journey she got married summer I
think 2014 or 2015 and then
um the next summer is when she filmed
season one of haters back off wow just
one year so yes so she went away for the
summer and all of us all of us me and
the comments I read at the time
um were just like why isn't she talking
about Josh anymore she's crying a bunch
she is not telling us why she's crying a
bunch Josh doesn't mention her anymore
just randomly yeah she would she would
like be crying in her Vlogs and she
would just talk about how she was having
a hard day she was feeling really
anxious and sometimes she wouldn't get
into it and um yeah it just caused a
bunch of people to wonder what was going
on Josh her husband got a dog which I
kind of see as he was like he got a new
companion for sure
um
yes so she came home to visit I remember
one time and they like barely even
vlogged together and it was very weird
and then at the end of the summer like
september-ish they both released
separate statements
that they were getting a divorce Amanda
donated she says she was only
homeschooled for one year well she talks
about being homeschooled literally every
every single day
Olivia knows her yeah like she
always refers to herself as The
Homeschool kid and it
so she in my opinion she goes up to film
this the show her co-star is her husband
now I mean come on even if they didn't
like weren't into it there was clearly
an emotional yeah so here we go I'm
gonna take you
what happened okay they announced their
divorce that December Colleen goes um to
Hawaii something that she she would love
to Vlog when she was in Hawaii and it
was that time of the year and Eric went
with them the guy who was in her show
the love interest from her show who is
one of her great friends we could tell
from like videos and stuff people were
just like oh interesting and Angela came
for like two days and then she left but
Eric stayed with Colleen and her family
and um people saw in the back of her
first day in Maui she was like doing a
little hula dance in the bathroom and
Eric's trunks were in
um oh the sink or like they were hanging
and so all of the comments were like
Eric showered in your room blah blah and
there's a clip of her the next day being
like you guys are so crazy you guys are
insane and then she had like a very
detailed story of how like they checked
in and the room wasn't ready so then
they went to the beach and then the
other room wasn't ready so he showered
in her room like she gave us an
explanation that's pretty nasty so she
was I think she was probably with him
then
what's up
wait do they have kids who Eric and
Colleen yeah not at this point okay no
so okay I got you no no no so that
happened Hawaii people are like oh I'm
shipping them but they're not together
because they keep saying they're just
friends
um Ben like a year goes by and then all
of a sudden in a video they announced
that they're dating
and then a week later they announced
that they are engaged and she is
pregnant okay listen maybe they're soul
mates and they're meant to be together
but I mean that's up you got
married a year ago I mean give it
some time lady she shares so much of her
life and she has a podcast with her
husband and the fact that they haven't
told the story of how they fell in love
they haven't no not really and they
don't give like days and they don't yeah
it's just the way she describes it is
that very quickly very quickly they
decided they were the person for each
other and then they wanted a baby can I
put out a theory I feel in a way she big
timed her ex-husband well if you yeah we
there are screenshots of her talking
about him with the children with the
children yes oh that sounds exciting wow
the kids got the front row seat through
a divorce they did and you know what I
wanted that like when I got my grubby
little fingers on these screenshots I
was like
oh my God the amount of time I spent
wondering
and trying to dissect videos so okay so
the summer after
okay Josh releases after they announce
they're having a baby he
um now he is sober and he's doing well I
think
um but at the time he was drinking very
heavily and he went on a live stream and
on that live stream he was very drunk
and very angry and he did say quote I
know what Colleen did to me my family
knows what Colleen did to me
um yeah why we've been speculating she
definitely cheated on yeah I don't know
come on
um but okay there it is got it so oh
is does that answer your questions about
I think so husband okay yeah
moving on oh yeah I was gonna say I
think she got caught up in this life of
Fame I think she was doing the show she
was amongst all these famous actors and
she big timed her she's like listen I
can do better maybe I need to date I
need to date up Adam said in the chat
she sent videos of Eric in the pool
during that Hawaii trip saying how sexy
he was
ew ew it wasn't that long after they
announced their divorce I don't know I
don't know I don't know you know too
much about this I know a lot about it
that's the truth all right here we go
next slide okay
okay my own personal credentials great
timing this is a card I made for Colleen
in 2014 when I went to one of her live
shows
um it says Colleen I put all my
scrapbooking stickers
let's be honest it's ugly right I was a
little more talented than that uh no
this is pretty great for a kid
okay this is impressive 2014 I was like
that's fine
okay well thank you so much for saying
that let's see the Taco Bell is that a
inside joke
what Taco Bell antique tea cow is
something she used to say all the time
Taco Bell was her favorite food
I'd like to talk about let's look at the
inside we respect that frankly oh I mean
I would you know me
so Colleen
hold on this is so iconic photo of you
oh it's insane
sure
a car ride home go ahead sir um Colleen
firstly I would like to tell you that
you have changed my life forever
I am a musical theater geek and then I X
this out because there's absolutely no
way I'm showing you what it is nope too
embarrassing
um but seeing who you are now even after
you were an awkward teen who didn't fit
in changed who I am how I present myself
and what I want to be oh
I want to be just like you is a crazy
thing for me to say I said in all caps I
want to be just like you
I hope one day I just want to wear your
skin guys this next line I hope one day
I am able to connect with people the way
you do
I don't want that here's the thing don't
feel bad this is this is actually a
really insightful because this is how
her fans see her then and also
they look to her like oh she's I was
very she's the cool adult yeah she's a
cool adult the big sister because you're
a kid you know yeah but it's real this
is actually super interesting yeah it's
crazy
um I hope to connect with people the way
you do
um I hope to find somebody who loves me
as much as Josh loves you whoops wow
oops when I got my wisdom teeth out all
I did was go home and re-watch your
video so I could smile and get through
it I love you Colleen you are my idol
love Olivia
so can I ask how did you you meant this
at the time right you meant all this oh
it's powerful I was obsessed yeah
so as we move on to this group chat just
put yourself in the state of mind that
clearly Olivia was in this is her fans
loved her
they idolized her it's very interesting
that you've got clearly you did not get
this letter to her
no I did these are photos I took before
I went to the show oh wow you hold on to
these for a while yeah
wow good for you thank you I would do a
PowerPoint one day yeah okay so you so
how did you deliver the letter to her
did you there was there like a meeting
yeah if you you brought it and then you
just leave it at the door with security
and they said that they would give it to
her they probably just threw that
no uh she read it she has Security's
like I'll throw all this out for you
guys just leave it with me
you know what I'd rather it that way
maybe maybe it would be better that way
I was young okay she did talk to
children
okay my own personal credentials there's
more that's I have a video of me crying
watching her get married
wow yeah there's more wait I can watch
the video of you you can if you want to
I can't believe I look that way
this is a re-upload yeah oh my God
you're so sweet
okay
did you ah so like how did you dig this
up
oh Snapchat stories oh it saves it yeah
wow you're so sweet can we believe this
she cheated on him a year later man she
had me crying yeah
crazy
yeah this is this is amazing okay and
then next
um my sophomore year of college this is
2019.
Colleen uh starred in waitress she got a
guest spot with Todrick Hall
um
and she was one of the leads and I loved
that Musical and I loved her so it was
my first week of school and I got myself
a ticket and I went to New York to see
her because in her Vlogs she was like if
you come and support me please come and
support me I will stay and talk with all
of you I said and she was like talking
about how she stays for hours and she
was like really hyping it up about like
she talks to the people who go for her
and she like even had a time when a girl
wasn't there for her so she didn't talk
to her it was like there was drama
happening so I was like I need to go I
need to be there a girl wasn't there
what was that there was a girl who
didn't go see the show and was just out
there to meet her and didn't have a
program yeah and and she talked to her
yeah and uh in one of her Vlogs she
tells a story about how like no
you didn't you didn't
get a ticket so she didn't talk to her
she did talk to her but she was like you
guys like don't show up if you're if
you're not so you waited outside to meet
me all right so yeah even though you're
a child that doesn't have so I'm just
trying to understand this she was
berating the child who didn't pay for
the ticket no no no no no this is this
is a this is a tangent but she does have
a video where she was talking about a
girl didn't have a program and the
mother was like please just talk to her
like she loves you and so in her Vlogs
she complained that night about how
some people are getting
more than others and others are spending
more money and it's not fair and oh my
God okay so where did you fly from for
this Ohio
okay so you did a whole trip this year I
did and
Ohio
yeah so I stayed at
that
stage door for good seats too huh I did
yes I stayed for at least an hour and a
half I think and
she didn't talk to many people really
she schmoozed with like the front row
she had people give their programs in
like stacks of ten and push them up so
she could sign them and put them back I
understand it's a lot of people
I just thought that I was gonna know her
you know like that's the way she made it
seem yeah we're gonna get to yeah and
that's Corey right there holding the
bags and he was one of her best friend
he is one of her best friends I was
obsessed with him I thought he was
hilarious hey where is he he's the one
his back has turned holding the bags
on the in the photo on the right
this video
no no no go back to the slide oh
foreign
yeah so that's a photo I took at the
stage door Colleen's in the striped
shirt Corey is wearing the bags Corey
didn't talk to one person he stood
against the wall with like a very sour I
am not one to be like they seemed very
not happy and I think I gestured toward
him like can I please have a photo and
then I saw someone actually ask and he
was like stop or he said something like
No And I was like
oh okay so okay wow so the experience
was when you left how were you feeling
about it I was very very sad I was with
my sister she remembers yeah yeah
disappointed I was very disappointed
that's a great way to put it because I
still have the play I mean I still have
the play bill just because at the time I
didn't let it good thing you saved all
this yeah I know right
Dan are you loving this story
yeah yeah that's Dan Dan Dan is not why
why why what you always look like uh
you're just not a drama fiend like me I
get it oh yeah no I mean
he's dealing with the tech issue I want
to be yeah I don't want to be a hater
why are you put me on the spot like all
right no I don't really care about this
no I don't yeah I mean that's okay it's
okay that you don't care about it I
didn't until I saw Olivia crying now I
mean yeah this this I can't this
presentation has been funny I I enjoyed
the uh video of It's a teenager Olivia
crying over a TV show but I will say I
did drop a few tears last night while I
was making this it was like weird and
like personal in a crazy way well you
were also there's you're invested in
this I was invested there's a clip in
here
um from one of Adam's videos that really
really made me
very upset anyway here's this is you
shooting uh yeah we saw it was very
interesting so let's move on to the next
one okay so this is the catalyst
all of this
March 2020.
Colleen posts as Miranda Sings surprise
announcement 30 minutes you're not ready
and it looks like Miranda's about to
come out
that does look like that right
um Miranda then posts I have a secret
I'm coming out today for you all this
has been so hard to come to terms with
but I'm proud I stand before you today
as a Meghan Trainor fan I hope you can
all accept me that's like a funny joke
but it is queerbaiting and people
pointed it out so Colleen released this
statement what we did not know at the
time
next
well hold on I want to read the
statement okay it's basically just her
saying I'm sorry that I did that it's
this is very not me I deleted it yeah I
think if you did that joke today it'd be
more obvious like
people will be like dude that's
that's not cool yeah I guess queer
bidding was like this was 20 summer
2020. I mean yeah spring okay not that
it was ever okay okay don't come from
Jesus Christ I hear the grumbling
already
Colleen Ballinger says I agree with you
and I regret it which is why I deleted
it I'm deeply sorry Miranda is a
character
oh she's I I hate that excuse just a
character by the time I base the
character on people who are idiots I'll
see people do awful and then do it as
Miranda and show them how idiotic it
looks but this shouldn't have been
tweeted okay queerbaiting is wrong
period I am the biggest supporter and
Ally
of the lgbtq plus community and the fact
that I disappoint people in that
Community is devastating okay good
apology
what we did not know at the time
was it done without the it's a character
thing yeah go ahead sorry the person
behind those tweets was Adam McIntyre
one of Colleen's
um most dedicated fans
with the best intentions might I say
um Adam identity
Adam's gay Adam was 17 at the time he
didn't need to know better wait hold on
hold on hold on which tweet so so the
the coming out I'm coming out as a
Meghan Trainor stand yeah if you
So Adam was working for Colleen
in those group chats he would give her
ideas and then they would
DM back and forth and it happened so
often that she ended up giving him her
login to post her on her socials on her
socials for Miranda Sings yes and
um Adam so he wrote this he had cleared
this idea with her before he posted it
so he wrote this
no I don't I don't know if he wrote the
the I agree with you I regret it he made
the Meghan Trainor tweets I'm Mr Miranda
yeah yeah almost okay yeah
so
um
it did not go over well
she let him know
he if you go to the next uh slide
so she messages him
it's all anyone is talking about I'm
really upset I never would post
something like that now everyone thinks
I'm homophobic I'm really really upset
okay hold on so she's getting and
then she talks to 17 year old Adam is
Like You she's kind of like it's
your fault she's kind of blaming it on
him I see right okay when he was a 17
year old who did not know better and did
not she gave him her login that's crazy
I wanna
hell no man yeah I'll never give that
out to anybody let alone a child
um and everybody he apologized profusely
and was like I logged out everything's
okay like I'm I'm so sorry
um and then she ghosts him
and they her his Idol stops talking to
him and then he begins to hear he was
kicked out of weenies she kicked him out
of weenies for this
she dropped his ass from the group chat
and Adam was told Adam was told
that they were talking about him
that is so messed up yes so this in the
middle that is a text that Adam then
sent to col uh yeah sent to Colleen
saying I've been told by multiple people
that you and Corey have been running
around saying I run a hate account for
people who uh for people who support you
which is extremely disappointing that
your mind would go to that place I'm
aware and so are my parents um and have
screenshots of everything from the past
few weeks that Corey has said about me
and in relation to you about me in these
group chats and also everything else
before but never thought you'd stoop to
that level especially due to the 17 year
old age Gap talk to me in 16 years if a
33 year old takes advantage of Flynn for
years and then runs talking
run talking him on Twitter you want
to play that game why do you even bother
following me so she was 33 yeah holy
yeah
she was 33 and she was playing she was
playing a Mean Girls game with a 17 year
old yes who was working for her for free
yes posting to her social accounts mind
you she was talking to him like one day
like if this works we'll get you set up
and like we'll get you an actual
position like she was she was promising
him a job pretty much if things went
well and he was one of the chosen
weenies so they were the favorites he
was the he was like the favorite and she
kicked him from the group I can't get
over how mean girl that is
and so at the top this screenshot on the
right is from Colleen's video so her
messages are going to be on the right
she responded to Adam take advantage of
Flynn what are you talking about what
does Flynn have to do with everything
how dare you bring my son into your
drama I didn't say anything about you
I've never said anything but nice to you
I've never been anything but nice to you
I haven't said one word about you I'm
not gonna argue with you or talk smack
about you I just wish blah blah blah
um Adam's mom then responds to Colleen
and says this is Adam's mom oh yeah it
is not nice when your child is brought
into things
but if you have read it correctly you
would have seen that he wasn't and it
was a comparison that was being made
mother to Mother you may now understand
never speak my son's name again and tell
your son uh and tell your Sidekick the
same applies to his oh your Sidekick
yeah okay listen bad ass let's go no if
I'm Colleen
which is hard to put myself right in the
situation but once you get the message
back from the mom I have a feeling
that's kind of a little bit scary
because all of a sudden accountability
becomes a real thing right you're like
oh talking to an adult now yeah
yo this is crazy yeah this is just 2020.
we are not even close oh my God so
Adam post this video Colleen Ballinger
stop lying okay after this stuff happens
and because his Idol totally dropped him
he felt very exploited very used very
hurt and they were talking about
him so we posted this video where he
tells the story of the exploitative
relationship and being dropped what was
the time and what was the time
difference between their Fallout and
this video this video was posted April
28th and the Miranda Sings coming out
tweets were March 26th
so like a
so like a month a month yeah
that's super effed up yeah like girl
like let's be real
whatever he tweeted even if he just
tweeted something super racist and
messed up I mean that's a far cry but
like you gave him your log in account
whatever
yes whatever he does there is your fault
yeah end of story also she okayed the
idea she told Adam it was a good idea
well then there really is up
right so in this video Adam doesn't
touch on like the inappropriate text
messages he like alludes to the fact
that she would talk to him sometimes
about her divorce but he did not include
the screenshots that you will see later
that are very explicit and weird
um but he did include this moment from a
live stream when Colleen was giving away
clothes and she ended up sending
lingerie to Adam okay
let's watch
please give me the dress
oh my God these those clothes are nasty
he's so rude oh my God
you guys you're killing me okay
oh my God he's so sassy
oh my God this is hilarious
uh Adam just donated or left a comment
he said no Adam a member for six months
he says um
no she approved the tweets four times he
said or maybe maybe he said that before
you yeah and then he said thank you
Olivia yeah yeah yes Olivia knows
everything out don't worry
thank you he says he was 14 at the time
with the bra yeah oh at this time yeah
it's four
th when this live stream happened and
she sent him the bra he was 14. do you
do you when's the last time like any of
you guys actually look spent time with a
14 year old like they are children right
you forget how young how immature a 14
year old is it's it's a child like
really look at a picture of you when you
were 14 you're like oh my God 14.
right
that one sounded legit
of course is still chilling with
lingerie on ew that's an ugly shirt no
put that shirt in the bin
she's reading she's going over his
Twitter account she's laughing at all
the funny stuff he says you want the bra
I don't know do you want the brown
panties tweet right now that's Corey oh
my God that's like lingerie that's not
even like a bra right yeah that's and
panties that's like it's a matching set
it had the tags still on however she did
still it Adam made it very very clear in
his new videos when he's talking about
this that Colleen um in her apology
video which is in the next slide
um
she didn't show the part where she says
do you want it Adam she says in her
video oh Adam wants the panties which is
which came later when Adam responded was
like yes I want them yes I want them yes
I want them please send me something so
so why is it interesting why were the
panties out why was the lingerie you
were it was a Forever 21 haul and they
were going over like through clothes
that she doesn't want anymore okay yeah
okay
you want he's in Ireland okay
I'm sending him something
oh my God that made me laugh dude stop
what is he doing
you said you cheated me so hard okay
maybe he'll want the panties although
then his parents will be like you're not
allowed to watch who is sitting you
panties yeah that's actually funny
because that's what happened yeah yeah
you knew that argument it was like that
so I'm just trying to I'm trying to I'm
trying to internalize this whole pan
emailing business right
he's 14. you'll see I have linked her
response to it when in her apology
you'll hear her explanation for it I
mean yeah but if we want to deep like
deconstruct it morally that's a crazy
thing that she did that's what I'm
trying I'm just trying to I'm trying to
understand her perspective I'm trying to
understand I mean he's 14 if Adam's mom
is like where did you get this pair of
lingerie oh my favorite YouTuber said
yeah mailed it to me
like you gave your address like I
I know that that's not dangerous and it
wasn't ever a dangerous thing but like
just I would be like you gave you gave
someone on the Internet or a dress
he's a kid though no it wasn't his fault
it's the adult's fault let me send you
lingerie give me your address if nothing
else it really shows an extremely poor
decision-making uh capacity absolutely
for her and
on both of their parts
and she's her ass is 30. yeah
so did we see enough here yes we have
seen enough here okay so
Colleen's apology video this is her
response well hold on so what was Adam
uh we uh Adam talked about the bra stuff
in just the bra stuff you talked about
the bra stuff and their relationship and
how she had worked and how he had worked
for her and she did he didn't get paid
and all the stuff we talked about with
the with the mom DM and everything did
he say that he was kicked out of the
group and all this or did they did the
Tweet come up the pride tweet come up
the pride tweet or the Meghan Trainor
that was the Catalyst for everything
yeah so he talked about that in his
video everything we've talked about is
out in the world at this point
okay and he showed the DMS and
everything yeah yep and I remember when
this video came out it was a pretty big
deal because I remember seeing his video
it's amassed over 3.7 million views so
that's pretty significant right okay so
she responded yeah I linked the
time stamped let's take a look someone
had made a video saying some shocking
and hurtful things about me and a lot of
you wanted me to address it and I didn't
I didn't address it not because I was
just ignoring it and hoping it would go
away but because when this person
messaged me letting me know they were
upset I responded
she's already characterizing this in a
up way she's saying this person
yeah 14 year old child who was obsessed
with you and you were their hero slash
maybe still are this person I mean
you're already stretching the truth with
even that right immediately I was very
shocked and confused I expressed I
didn't know what they were talking about
and I also expressed frustration that
they were trying to bring my son's name
into their drama then I received a
message from this person's mother asking
me to not speak his name so I was trying
to respect the mother's wishes and the
parents wishes of this 17 year old but
it has gotten to a point 17 or 14. he
was 14 when the bra was sent he was 17
when she he posted the Meghan Trainor he
continued to be a fan of hers for three
years yes and then hit the fan yeah
after the Meghan Trainor tweet yeah a
very dedicated fan
got it
where there are so many rumors and lies
and speculations going around I
could dress it I do have receipts
proving the things that I'm about to
tell you however so she's saying the
reason she kicked him out of the weenies
Group is because of the moms no she's
saying that she didn't want to address
this because the mother said in her
message do not speak my son's name again
yeah I'm sure that's why you didn't talk
about it right
already public the biggest issue that
came from his video is that I sent a
child underwear and wow anyone who heard
this out of context and was offended I
completely understand because I would be
too but in this situation context is
everything so I would like to give you
some context to this situation four
years ago I did a live stream and in
this live stream I did a giveaway I was
giving away clothes that were unused tag
still on brand new that I had just
bought that I did not want one of the
items that was in this box was a really
ugly pair of underwear as soon as we
pulled them out before and I started
laughing and joking around about how
ugly they were why did I buy these
ridiculous underwear it was so stupid I
just got a big old box from Forever 21
and I want to open it up in front of you
guys maybe I'll send the ones I don't
want to you guys I got a bunch of crop
tops
the panties the panties
and people started asking for them in
the live stream what was that that brawl
you want the bra everyone wants the bra
bra the end of the live stream I was
done giving away clothes and then this
boy who made this video about me
recently he asked for the underwear yay
we picked people I think that's enough
did that boy
tell me what he wants what do you saying
he said
um hi you have ugly clothes but I want
those ratchet panties and bra signed by
court she didn't include the clip of her
going you want the bra Adam
okay which is what the first thing was
right which is just an it's an
interesting edit so yeah a little
selective for sure
it was so ridiculous it doesn't really
matter who who initiated it if she's 30
and he's 14. she should have said he
asked for it if you offered it it
doesn't matter to me I mean
you you still did that okay so the
reception was really great so I remember
I was lightly following all this stuff
as it happened and I watched her video
and I was like oh okay that all makes
sense
um
yeah it was really
people forgave her very quick
um the two top comments this is a good
apology video she isn't crying over
dramatically or blaming anyone else she
is taking responsibility for her
mistakes which is very mature good job
Colleen in this video she also
um addresses old clips that surface of
her being very insensitive and racist
and fat phobic
um so she addressed that also in this
video she has dressed everything hence
the title addressing everything right
and is there any more worth watching
this or no no
so she's basically just like he wanted
it
and that's what happened right
so
[Music]
okay so why was that misleading in a
sense or why why was she ultimately she
still sent panties to a child right
so but the whole concept of her
exploiting a relationship with a minor
she really minimized that hadn't come
out it was the closeness right yes and
everything that was really okay right so
the response is the Colleen James
Charles of course who is the moral
Arbiter of YouTube Right absolutely if
anybody knows how to treat miners with
respects is Jay is James Charles
oh no oh no oh no oh no listen
James James wouldn't have around
with you Adam he wouldn't waste your
time he would have asked for a dick pic
right out the gate arm armpit can I see
your armpit hair Adam
not me it's a joke don't send me
pictures do not submit that okay so
James tweets is literally all lies the
boy begged Colleen for the panties for
years he ran at this time they were like
collabing and stuff so they Bulldogs he
begged
for years I know that it took hold on to
actually send them
um wait I don't know if he's 14. so
according to James Charles since he was
11. he's been begging for her panties
no way yeah he ran her Twitter for one
day and she ghosted him either in and
she never ghosted him either in fact he
tried to bring Flynn into his argument
which we've seen that's not really what
he was doing
who cares he was talking about I'm a kid
Flynn is also a kid think about it
doesn't matter what he said yeah sure
his story doesn't look the best but he's
looking for attention since Colleen
won't give it to him anymore and y'all
are feeding it instead even if she did
address it people would say she's
attacking a minor let her take care of
her family and son during this pandemic
and worry about something else please
I'm tired of seeing myself that was the
pandemic that was there this was
pandemic time holy it's been going
for a long time yes really quickly
um the reception and the response to
Colleen Ballinger's uh the Colleen
Ballinger stopped lying this Cody who
was in our players earlier who is one
person in the fandom who was of age
um posted a video basically debunking
Adam's video okay so that would be cool
took that and believed that ran with it
and also forgave Colleen
with her apology those two videos went
hand in hand okay I can see that being
compelling right but now so I can only
imagine Adam must have been on the
receiving end of a lot of a lot of hate
especially with James Charles being like
so much hate uh
I love that James Charles is defending
her in this moment I mean it's a poetic
really truly okay so do we can I see her
video
um no
she has now since left the internet okay
um I'll tell you why later
we'll get there okay so I
no colors it was basically it was
essentially you'll see the the
construction of the video later it's
basically she paints Adam as uh as like
a manipulative person in in the video
it's crazy
so so I went to the next slide right
okay response to Colleen Ballinger this
is what she tweeted out nobody asked me
to make a video I was already doing one
I reached out to Colleen first and then
she replied two days later she and Corey
talked to me and showed me stuff to help
me learn the truth I then did my own
research and I found a lot more things
so like that the fact that they were she
even had missed they were she was
collaborating she was in her ear yeah
she was sending you re stuffed right but
this was the extent to which we got
their Communication in 2020.
well
[Music]
so
next okay
three years later despite all of the
hate that that situation brought Adam
he is thriving as a content creator he
is now amassed over 156k followers and
he um did gain I think he gained an
audience from the Colleen Ballinger stop
lying possibly I think that's the first
time I saw him and then I had watched
his drama videos because of it
um I'll be honest there was a moment
where
I knew of Adam
and then I there I had a moment where I
realized he was the Colleen stop lying
kid and I was like what the you
didn't realize they were the same yeah
so that was his first video the Colleen
video
um it was his first big video that got
him on the map if it wasn't his first
very interesting yes
so
June 2023 baby we're here this month
we're here that's now we've arrived this
is happening that's not it was in June
this year
so Cody comes out with a video basically
showing that Adam was right the entire
time
she shows this DM from Colleen after
Adam posted the Colleen stop lying video
in 2020 she messaged I want to reach out
to you privately and in confidence and
let you know why I'm staying silent
after he sent me that last message that
he has now made public I responded to
his messages immediately I did not ghost
him Adam begs to differ and then
received a message from his mother
through his DM asking to not speak of
him I now realize I should have never
been communicating with him in the first
place however which is crazy because she
was it wasn't just one 17 year old it
was oh yeah Adventures she went back and
then her other 13 year old friends about
it yes
um
I now realize I should have never been
communicating with him however he is
lying about a lot and showing things out
of context and will get major backlash
she's in her 30s and key is 17. we'll
get major backlash if I were to expose
that but I'm trying my best to respect
his family's wishes and protect him as a
minor as best I can I'm sad and
disappointed about all of this and I'm
just trying to keep it together so that
was like the first message that caused
Cody to make her video pretty
manipulative yes and there are so Cody's
video the one that exposed that has now
been taken down but thankfully Adam did
a wait why the old one or the new one
the new one why'd it get taken down
because it came out that uh Cody
actually did it for the wrong reasons
and they got exposed for the same thing
because they were always of age and also
in group chats with minors wait wait
wait wait wait wait so now the police
being canceled what's up
this girl's also now being canceled yeah
Cody is you being co-canceled yeah
yeah co-counselor but isn't she doing
the right thing what did she do well she
did bring the information to the surface
however
um it seems like I guess they didn't
really even care that Adam was getting
any sort of comeuppance it was just
she uh Cody was upset that Corey had
blocked them on Twitter and that was
what caused them to make the exposed
video she didn't do it for the right
Reason Not For Adam yeah
okay but it just so happened that
Adam's truth came out why the did
Cody blocker that's just what it is yeah
he's like you've got to get caddy girl
okay so so I see what she's doing though
she's I this is manipulative she wants
her to make the video obviously and
yeah these are super fans it's easy to
manipulate them if you're Colleen I
don't think it's
I don't think it's an issue right for
her
so um if you click I have time stamped
Adam's response I want to go back to
what I said about how young 13 14 year
olds are look at him
well no stunning oh yes on the left yes
it's crazy what you're the the clip
you're about to see is what made me cry
last night he's going through all his
old photos through like the years and
the fact that she was like talking about
wanting to like
expose him for lying when he wasn't when
he was a kid like it's just so crazy
so he's watching the he's watching oh
cancel the girls video
interesting social relationship with
this woman to the point where I was
being mean to a literal kid and then I
was like my plan is to paint the video
show Adam manipulates you into trusting
yourself
what yeah
I plan to Spain the video to show Adam
manipulated you
he is he's a child I know what he's not
what the and they're both of age
like this isn't a minor talking with
Colleen conspiring these are people of
age conspiring to bring down a minor
who was pretty much correct might I add
Miranda thing light girl you don't have
that be quiet no he's a kid I just like
you have no idea how awful that period
was and to literally see messages that
Colleen is like texting with someone
being like we're gonna frame this as him
being manipulative we're gonna frame
this as him being I mean the premise is
is laughable that this kid is
manipulating an adult woman a famous
adult yeah exactly I mean it's uh
although I gotta say I mean she how old
was she at the time 18 33 no no you mean
Cody yeah um
I didn't get an exact age I know that
they were over 18.
I mean she's a victim in all this too
isn't she sure yeah I mean in terms of
power Dynamic and talking to someone
you're a fan of parasocially absolutely
you'll have to explain more why she got
canceled I I need to understand that
better because I don't get it
I honestly don't know if I know enough
about that
okay fair enough yeah fair enough
well we're gonna frame this doing all
this
and the worst part about it is like
sorry I'm trying my best to hold this
together because I know people will be
like oh you're
I just to give just to back Adam up here
I've been on the receiving end when the
whole internet hates me as a as an adult
and it is once I described it to ELA I
was like it feels it genuinely feels
like somebody died every week yeah and
so as a child I can't imagine James
Charles and all these Mega
famous YouTubers talking about you
and then all their fans saying
especially as like a major consumer of
YouTube and you know who all of these
people are you watch them
I mean these are the formative years of
his life so like this yeah this is this
is heavy stuff um people are saying that
Cody was 30.
oh which is yeah that's crazy
she was 30 at the time that's what uh
Adam said uh that Cody is 33 now
that is interesting yes
um Adam's about to show the photos of
him as a kid or whatever I can respect
that
but
hold on I just wanna
to a literal kid and then I was like my
plan is to paint the video show Adam and
again Cody is a victim too so this is
not against Cody but this is before also
the Cody drama happened where
Cody wasn't doing it for the right
reasons
okay I don't know guys go easy on Cody I
think I don't know I don't know I don't
know everything I don't know nothing
about it Crossing them I had a master
plan to take you down what do you got
mad about the Miranda thing like girl
you don't have that
I just like
whenever I read that and like I look at
like these
this kid manipulated Miranda yeah
dressed up like Miranda before a live
show I'm so excited for the Miranda show
and it's like me is like a kid
or like me at the meet and greet or
something like that
or like just like the countless times
that like whatever and it was like
to know that like
to know that like one day like these
were the things that she would be doing
to me or you know
was this tweet drama ever
fleshed out more what do you mean like
we
shh
he she approved the Tweet she did and
there I never talked about
no
Colleen hasn't talked about the fact
that she approved those tweets um
interesting
like I would have I would have not
believed you at all
I would not have believed you
it would not have been on my
I wouldn't have believed you
I wouldn't believe you
so
just to go back a bit here
on this uh DM she showed so
it looks like Colleen is there more I
guess I should keep watching but it's
um you don't have to keep watching I'm
that's here it just says enough info
she's saying I'm gonna do all this stuff
trust me Colleen let me save you here
the DMS will be your salvation she says
to her and then Colleen says I'm sorry I
need to do the right thing and respect
his mother's wishes
so she's saying that I'm not going to
send you any of the stuff you're asking
for like no she ended up sending oh she
did
she's she wasn't gonna say anything
because she didn't want to go against
his fault his mother's wishes no she
just didn't want to write down yeah she
didn't want to be the one to say Adam so
she wanted something you can't say
anything written down where she's like
yeah go
slander this kid because at this point
some DMS have already been shared she
got a little taste of that and so she's
like I can't write anything out anymore
and
um
but the fact she sent the screenshots
and everything to him says it all
I mean in terms of
her involvement
okay interesting next yes so Cody's new
video in in this video Cody raises new
allegations
Cody talks about the weenies group chat
um Adam hadn't talked about the weenies
group chat before as we talked about
earlier 23 people were in it including
Colleen and Jessica and Cody who were
all of age
um and children
so that screenshot you'll see it in
the next one if you go next this this
yeah yeah okay
so let's talk sex with kids
um so here she asks are you a virgin to
all these children she also asks what's
your favorite position
she says are you a virgin right here
and then she says what's your favorite
position yeah seems like even the kids
were a little bit like you'll see
speechless in one of the ones
coming up Adam basically is like ew stop
it why why would she ask that
how would you ask that question I don't
know
to children
yeah
what's your favorite position
man
what yeah
uh there are there's more
um here she says tell me all the
thoughts you had when you uh first got
your periods please and thank you
example I thought I myself because
the blood was so dark in my underwear
just like a weird that's weird
please tell me all the well it's really
intimate she wants to like really have a
intimate intimate relationship with
these people kids
um okay so in this next one Adam with
the blue arrows here it says he says my
ass looks so good today y'all what's his
what's this profile I think it's a photo
of Miranda Cosgrove it was probably just
a funny meme okay but that's all photo
um and then Colleen responds picks Adam
ew and then Adam responds go away
which is a pretty good Adam said my ass
looks good and she asked for pictures
yes
which is weird
and how old was he in during this one I
think like 14
ah what the so these screenshots
now are her um if you go to the next one
operation bully my ex with all of these
children she hears she says he's lied to
everyone and said I cheated when would I
cheat when I was working 24 hours a day
uh yeah you're 24 hours a day with the
dude you ended up yes dummy it's
also just like all the responses of the
kids being like I've never heard a soul
but I'll kick him in the balls like if
these are yeah these are kids that
you're talking to
um she says it makes no sense he tries
to get pity for being heartbroken over
me when he constantly tries to drag me
through the mud you can't be heartbroken
over someone you hate so which is it yes
that's such an immature yeah that's such
an immature mindset which makes sense
yeah but if you read the responses from
the kids
he will regret it yeah I'll never hurt a
soul but I will kick him in the balls
ugh I'll start swimming it
let it out it feels good is it isn't
this slander or harassment
please tell me you know me and aren't
lying because I'm just a fan and don't
care about wait what is that one please
tell me please tell me you do know me
and aren't lying because I'm just a fan
and you don't care about cuz yikes
I don't understand that one I don't know
it was a child so
wow yep more bullying her ex she says he
was always mad when I was happy I
thought that would end when we split I
got him a tour I got him subscribers I
gave him a family I paid for everything
I flew wherever he was I gave him
subscribers man what more could he want
from me literally
is he a YouTuber is he yeah he uh he's
less so now after the divorce he's
really transitioned and he moved back to
Georgia has a wife
um but he used to Vlog every day he was
very good friends with Julian solomita
okay yeah
um
yeah but like the the broader context of
her
at complaining like in a serious like
way about her marriage yes the children
is pretty stunning yeah and these
children who think that they are a part
of the relationship right
right
the next one
um tampon in mouth this is a video that
Colleen sent in the weenies group chat
and then she encouraged the others to do
it as well
[Music]
and so this is a recent tweet I'm
assuming yeah yeah everything now has
just surfaced so Adam in a sense was
he wasn't going all out on her back then
no because he never even mentioned any
of this until recently he was I
think he was really really really hurt
that he thought that he was helping his
Idol and he didn't do anything wrong
because she did approve it
and then he was just dropped
and he was 17 and really hurt
the fact that he didn't mention any of
this stuff until now I think is a is a
point in his favor yeah I agree
uh Adam says the weenies group chat
consisting of mostly 13 to 17 year olds
I was a part of with Colleen all had an
inside joke calling started to do with
periods or some and she sent us
this video and all of us had to go out
and buy tampons and reenact it for the
group chat it was so weird
okay
oh we have the video oh my God they have
the receipts
why is that even when it's longer just
wait oh there's more
I don't what's funny about that I swear
I'm not high
an adult
it's not even like funny at all
and so they started sending their own
videos of them doing that yeah if you go
to the next slide Adam did kind of like
a round table with two of the other uh
two other members of the weenies chat
and they talk about the tampon situation
the weenies group chat Ramsay Becky and
Adam all talk
here it is a thing but you know what's
so weird about the about the tampon
thing yeah I just like you guys see my
period And I used my tampon yesterday
because we all took the pictures like
having the tampon in our mouth whatever
she she ended up messaging me
she ended up messaging me on Snapchat
and said hey Adam you weren't at the
meet and greet she was like would you be
able to go away and buy a tampon and
take a picture so you're included in the
picture that I think it was like Ella
was making yeah so we can Photoshop you
and yes she asked me to do it
with the tampon in our mouths because
that was the inside joke yeah she asked
me to go out and buy Tamp and I was like
14 or 15. she asked me to go out and buy
tampons to put one in my mouth yeah and
then we have the photo yeah and and I
obviously didn't want to go out and buy
them so I remember I got a Q-tip and
wrapped toilet roll around it and that
was me doing the photo because I didn't
remember that Adam I remember
well now that you met do they show the
photo
um I don't think so
well that's really weird yeah
that's super weird
yeah
that's what the that's super weird
dude that's some weird like
I mean fetish maybe I don't know
some of the comments on that tweet yeah
we're accusing it of being I can't tell
if it's like
it could be I can't tell I just know it
I can't tell if it's a fetish thing or
if she's like insanely infantile or I
mean she's she's there's clearly
something going on here that is not
normal right
yeah she's building up like these weird
reasons for them to do weird things like
oh we've got to take a picture you've
got to send this to be included right ah
there's something sells in that
there's something oh yeah the whole
thing is very sus right but there's a
there's an exertion of power to yeah
she's exerting her power to humiliate
Adam says he can send me the photo
thank you for offering though
um there was also another group chat
called Corey's this was Corey's
group chat with kids here yes with a K
though so I don't know
that makes it for kids right he sends
actual porn to them okay he said what
the is on my timeline no he does
not cheers my dude so wait are they okay
so they're the list
you go ahead okay so their relationship
her and her friend who lived together
for no good reason and are both
at this point like flirting with kids
I mean Adam just said he's DM the
picture to you Ethan on Twitter do you
want to see
huh I can't see what you're seeing so I
don't know and you preview the next
screen what the next slide or just take
it off my screen what do you mean what
is this
what what is in this photo it's covered
no but what is this what is it of
what do you mean what is this what is
this photo of Adam says that it was sex
but it's covered
it's not all covered
oh
okay let's skip it do you see what I'm
saying I mean I see I see some
going on there that's just legs
okay
well
if it's borderline just just skip it
we'll just cut well I wanna I wanna show
I can make another real quick I can read
it I can read it it's I think that it's
covered but to be safe no
um he sent to the children what the
is on my timeline the first message from
a child is I'm almost 18. someone says
off someone says what the
those are all kids
hold on hold on I want to show it but we
just got to edit it out more just to be
safe I see the photo Adam sent me the
photo he blurred out all the kids face
that's good it's really really really
weird
um Adam has has this photo never been
shown because this is pretty
insane
this is really insane
that's really insane
I don't want to be the first person to
show this though
yes it's her with like a bunch of kids
and they all have tampons in their mouth
can you go backwards Ethan and then go
back to this slide and see if it's
covered now I just put something over it
no
Let me refresh it yeah if you refresh it
might
it was slide 34. okay yeah good job
thank you you're good so there was do we
know what the picture was of I think
legs now Adam says that there was a
sexual act in the video that he sent
okay
so he has a why does he have a separate
group chat with the kids right that's
super weird Corey's
where he sends them pictures of porn and
he said or videos of porn he says what
the is on my timeline right and now
it's on these kids is personal group
chat and eyes yeah
that's that's that's illegal actually
that's a question
yeah that's just something that guy
should be in you that I mean yeah that
guy just committed a crime right you
definitely can't send porn to kids
as a grown ass adult
um
the next one wait somebody says
oh the wait okay hold on
people have seen oh the photo the photo
so can I show it I mean Adam has said uh
he says he's shown it because I do think
it's interesting as long as I can and he
blurred the faces
yeah okay then I'll show it
or yeah maybe I won't show it if you
want it necessary this is a bad idea
it's okay just to be safe just go look
at on atoms I mean and Adam uh is
specifying that he was not one of the
members of Corey's
he was not one of the chosen he was not
one of the kids talking about porn dude
what though and exchanging porn
okay moving on
um this is a voice memo that Corey sent
in a group chat with minors
okay this was from Corey's
I don't know if it was from Corey's
I know that it was from Corey
wow hey everyone it's Corey I just
wanted to record a voice memo because I
think a lot to say
um but first of all I just want to say
that like I love all of you like you uh
honestly mean so much to me oh my God oh
my God I know that it sounds weird
because is like a full-grown adult and
some of you are younger the fact he
acknowledges this
in the call yeah is stunning
this is like a trump call where he goes
yes it's uh I know that this is illegal
and I can't show people the documents
because I he's like here's the crime I'm
committing
it was a perfect call and they indicted
me
oh Corey should go to jail actually
he might be a sex criminal
they were yeah I don't know
they were talking about porn together
and you know that it sounds weird
because I'm older adult and something
that is insane that is a trump move
right there that's straight up
and this is really inappropriate I
should not be doing this but I love all
of these children so much yeah
and delete turn your phone off maybe
listen uh all my favorite kids yeah I
realize I'm an adult and it's super
inappropriate and potentially illegal
for me to send you uh porn but I love
you guys so much
I'm going to send you porn you guys are
13. I'm in my I'm 30. and I know what
I'm doing I know I I'm doing this I'm
not on any drugs I'm totally sober right
now
oh yeah
um
I it's so comforting to go online and
talk to you guys and and feel and feel
like loved and cared about because I
love and care about all of you
um and I trust you and like
I like with all my friends I vent to you
and when I'm angry and I feel better and
I feel comforted by you all and I hope
that I can do the same for you but like
this whole thing
with
crystal is has just escalated into
something really bad that he was just
talking about drama at the time that was
when Adam posted his first video in
2020.
so what's interesting about this is that
he spends that first 95 percent of this
saying how important they are to him
they're his only friends in the world
blah blah blah blah blah like uh I guess
it's like love bombing I guess maybe you
would call it and then at the end he's
like but I need you guys to do something
for me now who's he talking about
Kristen
I don't know who that is I think that
it's another person from the fandom that
was in some drama at the time it was
years ago
[Music]
something really bad
oh we don't even know what he's talking
about no it cuts off there just another
one of their
he's like this girl Krista I've been
sending porn to she's 11.
it's really bad you guys
[Music]
it was of right mind when I did it all
yo so now we're gonna get into some of
the individual stories of some of the
other members of the weenies chats
because they have also come forward and
told their own personal stories this is
like the worst Coming of Age movie of
all time crazy the weenies like the
goons the weenies but they're all just
groomed and used by a YouTuber weenies
Never Say Die
was a die-hard fan from the beginning
from when she lived in New York
and um
he continued on in the fandom and went
on to work on tour with her
and he tells his story about what it was
like to work for her and he looks like
he's grown up now he was of age when he
was on tour
okay remember when Corey made my life a
living hell the entire summer of bust
tour 2018 and no one did anything about
it how many points for that tell me more
this guy Corey seems like a real love
right winner yeah
there's something really odd when you
consider in totality
both of theirs behaviors and his
quarries is even potentially worse
although he's doing it in service to her
uh they're living together it continues
to come back to me as something really
weird
you want to read these uh yeah like when
he aggressively backed me into a corner
in Omaha and said look at how many
followers you have versus me I'm your
Superior I was 22. dude was like 30 plus
at the time one morning he barged into
our hotel room and screamed at me until
I cried he told me the night before he
wanted to sleep on the bus the morning
after he tried to make it seem like I
took the hotel Key without him knowing
and locked him out straight up traumatic
dude once he started seeing that I was
good at my job that's when it all went
downhill he didn't like when I got
praise or recognition it would only put
more of a Target on me and make the
bullying worse he's literally the reason
I was not asked back
um there's more weirdo
morning after you tried to make it
seemed like I took the hotel Key without
him knowing and locked him out
okay
as much as it pains me to say Colleen
played her part in all of this too she
would pull me aside and counsel me
during all of it telling me she was
proud of me for standing up for myself
Etc out of here when I finally
stood up to Corey he called for an
emergency meeting because he wanted me
out I was gaslit into apologizing so I
could keep my job and reputation they
all just sat there and watched him
torture me they knew it was happening
wow
um the next screenshot that's uh after
tour he sent in the group chat gonna
miss you all safe travels everyone and
two minutes later cortisol leaves the
group chat what the hell
no
right
that guy what is the deal right and then
the next slide is um the weenies have
like a little meme they love this video
of Corey looking all huffy walking with
a suitcase
that you mean the modern day yeah uh
weenies right the modern day weenies
today
this guy really is odd he's getting like
his whole purpose and self-worth from
being Colleen's sidekick that sends porn
to kids and nip blackmail or not
blackmail but manipulates kids into
doing their dirty work
oh man he is one weird dude yeah
so um that's Johnny's story this is
Becky's story she has a tick tock that
she posted where she tells it oh wait
this one is I made just a little bit
over 3 500 for this entire tour I was
taxed about 1500 of it at the end of the
year I worked this entire tour my
five-day trial run shows
the Netflix special I performed in the
show on top of my duties 12 plus hours a
day no shower no bed worth it
along with the tour how long was the
tour I don't know you could see the
dates but it's covered up to August it
was a summer tour
did I see a tweet of him saying that
they didn't want to they paid him hourly
but they didn't pay him when he wasn't
working I saw him tweet something like
that too
um I can do research on that and see if
I can find it he was like they
specifically told me that I wasn't gonna
get paid unless I was on the stage
working which is crazy because he's
traveling with them yeah
yeah I recall seeing that on Twitter
well you can see here it's from 7 11 to
looks like it was just over one month
based on I don't know how deep this goes
this picture
so
yeah I mean live touring is a 24-hour
job so the pay should be yeah
uh 3 500 for a month of that is pretty
bad I would say
I would say
yeah you should right you should be
getting paid 24 hours a day I do not see
that tweet but I will keep looking for
it okay good I don't know what I saw
Maybe
maybe you can search for it well
all right moving on Becky's story
another weenie this is the one you were
talking to me about
this is a crazy story
okay
oh this girl yeah and she was she a
weenie too I don't think she was a
weenie she was a prominent figure in in
the fandom okay I see I see traumatized
and now is
this I'm a girl in this video and this
video has one over a million views and
that is a lot of people to be seeing
this story without hearing it from me so
I want to explain this
so I was a fan of clean and all the
Ballinger Family for a very very long
time and I think in this video I was
about 16.
never been to a Miranda show Colleen
frequently has segments where she calls
people up on stage one of those segments
was the porn bit which I'm not really
going to be explaining in this video but
that's why I was kind of trying to dress
skin bees do you know what the porn bit
is I do know what the porn bit is so
Miranda
um thinks that everything is sinful uh
she's very religious and um she had this
bit where she would bring someone on
stage and point at them and be like you
are porn like you're dressed
inappropriate if they were wearing like
a dress or like shorts so she would she
definitely would look in the crowd for
who she could call porn okay and so it
would subliminally make kids be like oh
maybe I'll wear shorts that was like
some tongue-in-cheek shaming sure
yes yes
I mean not really
or
whatever not my words her words you got
it you got it
would be called up on stage and
basically get degraded by Miranda but I
did not get called up for that I got
called up for the yoga challenge
as soon as I stood up from the audience
I saw Queen's eyes widen because she
realized I was not wearing pants
but for some reason that didn't stop her
from continuing in fact no adult at any
point stepped in in this situation so we
get to the point in the yoga challenge
where I am laying down and Colleen is
spreading my legs basically as far as
she can she spent some so far that you
can see the spandex I was wearing under
my Romper which thank God I was wearing
now the original video posted by Xander
zandar I'm sorry if I pronounce her name
wrong is only a screenshot but there is
a whole video of this but that
screenshot is the most important because
that is the moment I will never forget
where I was laying under clean and she
was smirking down at me while thousands
of people were laughing and I was
terrified that my body wasn't covered
enough up enough by the spandex or the
romper
I basically felt naked so it felt
incredibly sexually violating I was
younger and my body was still developing
and I was still becoming comfortable
with myself so for her to use my body as
entertainment on stage really set
um my confidence back quite a lot and
not to mention after all this after the
show I had to walk back to my car where
there was many a men staring at me in a
very predatorial way that they were not
looking at me before because of how
exposed I had been on stage
so I literally did not feel safe leaving
the venue and I'm not saying this was
sexual assault although people are
debating that in that comment section
but as someone who has been sexually
assaulted this situation
gave me that same feeling where it feels
like you need to purge and like clean
out your insides you know just that
nasty gross feeling
there's a couple comments on Xander's
video being like oh she signed up for
that why is this such a big deal blah
blah Colleen exploited my minor body for
entertainment and money and did not
protect my safety at this show as an
outsider looking into this situation it
may seem like this wasn't a big deal but
this was really pretty scary for my
teenage self and especially someone who
loved and looked up to Colleen
and I could never say anything because
everybody loved her
but this is who she really is she uses
kids for her own gain I was a minor and
again she did not protect me
so if you're watching this and you're
thinking about taking your kids to a
Miranda show I would advise you to think
twice because you may come back with
years of trauma and I don't wish that on
anyone
this is definitely okay I mean that's
horrible the the
the continued theme is her yeah she just
she doesn't understand
she doesn't appreciate that she's
dealing with children or the way she
uses them and interacts with them Johnny
was
backstage and he tweeted out that um
everybody was very mad at her even her
husband for that yeah oh yeah
I was wondering that because as she was
telling that story I was like there had
to be like a stage manager or a producer
or touring manager who was like dude
this is gonna come back yeah apparently
apparently it caused contention okay
that is interesting to know
that's crazy right poor girl I know
that's crazy
I promise you guys on our live show on
Friday I will not be
serve
promise we'll do it well I can't promise
you won't be traumatized though because
once again we are playing a show
everybody the prolapse
right but I will warn you before that
time and there's no miners in the
audience either thank you 18 only Plus
thank you
if you're a miner do not come
you're not allowed do not come
18 plus you're not allowed do not come
listen to Camelot
is this another video Becky later posted
the video
um yeah do not oh the whole video Becky
did uh end up posting the video if you
want to see it is on her account I don't
know if we should watch it I mean if she
posted it yeah she posted it publicly I
mean you get the idea in the picture
though I mean you get it yeah you know
what I mean it
um this is Ella's story so Johnny posted
his tweets okay Colleen you want to play
Let's Play look what I found it's you
bashing one of your biggest fans at the
time this was sent we used to make fun
of them for editing fake freckles on
their face remember then you made fun of
them for being trans and gender fluid in
those it basically just says Colleen
sent a photo of this fan and said her
her freckles are gone and then also said
and she's using she her again
and so that was those those were those
he's gossiping with another weenie yeah
members
about other kids that that
okay that's nuts right and Ella
was very sick
through
um their love of Colleen and Colleen
knew that and um
that comes back into play in the next
slide that's like evil yeah Ella posted
on your fans your super
fans gossiping with other kids yeah what
are you doing that is so vile
why so she yeah was tweeting a bunch she
never liked me this is so sad I can't
believe it I honestly don't know what to
say what the why did you pretend to
like me I want to die Colleen is a
I'm literally shaking so
is this recent she just found out about
this yes this was like last week and
sheet I'm assuming I know he blurred it
but she found out that she was talking
about her for sure yes yes
um and then Johnny sent Ella a message
because in the text they were like wait
you didn't tell Ella beforehand that you
were posting that
um so then Ella posted Colleen said this
about me and it's a screenshot of a
message Johnny sent to Ella I'm still
stuck on this I mean it's so obscenely
mean it gets worse
this alone is enough to be like nah
you're done yeah
um so Johnny says to Ella I just
genuinely want you to know this is 100
hand on my heart things she said to my
face on bus tour I remember at Claire's
day we were sitting in front of the
hotel waiting for an Uber she told me
she believed you were faking your
illness to get closer I know and she was
in the works of writing a movie about a
girl who fakes illness to get close to
celebrities and then gets exposed as the
villain she was writing a defamatory
screenplay about you with her brother
Chris this feels so wrong telling you I
genuinely do not want to hurt you with
this information she's diabolical I'm so
sorry Ella
um Chris her brother denies this however
one of the characters in haters back off
her mother has fibromyalgia but it comes
out that she is faking it for attention
so there's definitely that exists
why is she so mean yeah
and then this is the last this is really
really bad
this is Oliver's Story another weenie or
just a random fan and um he would
message with Trent Ballinger who is one
of the Ballinger Brothers
um he's hard of hearing he has a
cochlear implant
um
Coley never really showed him on her
Channel she said that he liked to stay
private
um and then a lot of people were like
why are you keeping him hidden blah blah
and after enough comments were made she
then did like a coming or coming out
talking about my my brother's hard of
hearing and then which obviously got him
more attention from children I imagine
um and these are messages that he would
send to a 13 year old no I know no I
know
no I know I'm not ready to click I know
it is the it's so much 13. and it's so
bad
her whole family's up oh yeah
okay well I haven't seen it yet so maybe
it's fine maybe it's not that bad oh
it's bad it's horrible actually there's
Trent in the background who we're
talking about yes well let's take let's
review he looks wholesome yeah let's
review these two started a family
channel so they're oh no Rachel in the
middle is uh Colleen's sister she is
also a YouTuber but she's not married to
Chris Oh I thought this okay Jessica is
Chris's wife she's not in this I'm not
even gonna try to untangle is anyone in
her family a good guy a good Happy Hands
I don't know maybe a cousin yeah maybe a
cousin cousin maybe second cousin we
have to go back pretty far
um yeah so Trent says just don't share
our conversation with anyone anything we
talk always a good start between you and
I that's literally yeah love ya
it gets worse it literally like it just
gets worse okay
I'm so uncomfortable just from that
first line
that's like from the Groomer's handbook
nothing ever good follows that sentence
ever yep the next one
Trent says I'm told not to talk to
people under 18. when I was with them
just saying I know what yeah what's up
with that I do so just to spread
positivity so yeah Oliver says oh I
don't see anything wrong with talking to
people that are under 18 who said that
you really do spread positivity I love
it and Trent says family so family
apparently I guess knows that he talks
to people yeah this has happened and
they know about it right they said
please stop talking to Children right
although frankly she should take her own
advice right
[Music]
she didn't talk to kids there'd be no
story that this would all never have
happened correct
it's a good rule yeah for influencers to
follow
and R Kelly incidentally too
although that wasn't really what he got
he got in trouble for others I got it
okay
um so next one you don't look by so I'm
like head tilt Oliver says oh I don't
but yeah I think I am Trend says why do
you think you are you don't look by it
yeah what the is that I didn't know
um I don't want to have the uh the
bisexual lighting just blowing it on his
face at all times you don't have that
special hair yeah
the baby bangs
I don't know I just think I'm straight I
guess I don't I just don't think I'm
straight I guess and then Trent says
just be honest with yourself you're
young you don't have to label yourself
yet Oliver you're very right yeah but I
don't want to completely label myself I
guess the closest thing I am is being by
Trent asks why Trent is curious why I
don't know guess why would I think I'm
straight at what point I don't know but
I'm questioning and then Trent says how
old are you and Oliver says 13 and Trent
says yeah I wouldn't question it yet pea
pod which is what he called Oliver
why did he call
I don't know it's just that's yeah he
used to call her yeah pet name is like
another pretty uh standard grooming
thing is it not my little pea pod yeah I
don't know bro yes so I mean
this is insane this is like
straight up insane it's really bad
insane
2018. 13.
um Trent says night don't let the
sexuality bite
it's okay you're gonna grow up doing
what you love and probably fade away
from me
holy that's a really incriminating text
I know
guilt-tripping kind of
gross he's definitely okay I mean it
speaks for itself yeah
um P.S he's saying you should come to
Colleen's show in Orange County so let's
hang out basically oh my God I wish I
could my mom said I can't go to
California why not
um when I'm an adult I really want to
fly out to California by myself how long
do you have to go Trent asks the
earliest I could go would be summer 2023
I'll be 18. now this person just turned
18.
that yeah that
like I won't be interested in you then
yeah what is that emoji
that doesn't work for me yeah right
if you have any friends that might be
down
the next the next one is crazy
how old will you be Oliver says in
November Trent says yep almost 14 at
that point trans has four more years to
go he's doing the 18 year old countdown
clock in real time on them
holy it's really not good
especially interesting considering again
there's the implication that he's done
this and they know about it and they
still taken his ass on tour and
right I don't know if they take him on
tour
um but she did do a video of a major
video with him
there's some ish I mean yeah that family
I don't know what it is is there
anything known about her parents about
like her
um Mom I don't know I know that her dad
was
exposed last week for having a YouTube
playlist with an inflation fetish I saw
that yeah is that in this no it's not
um it was running a little bit long so I
took it out but he does not too fetish
because he's not done anything wrong
it's just it's just very funny and very
embarrassing it's titled want
just want we gotta show that it's crazy
a living rabbit
but uh let's continue we'll we'll do
that after you can pull that up baby
next slide
so next slide
um Trent sent Oliver a video of themself
and said you kind of looked like my last
girlfriend in that pic when Oliver was
13.
okay so hold on hold on hold on what did
he send what is this it's a picture of
that's a picture of Oliver at the time
okay and Trent says he accompanies it
with you kind of look like my last
girlfriend in that
dude
and then
Oliver says that Trump would always Send
this photo of them to them that Trent
would edit so Trent sent this to Oliver
and said I think I made you pop out more
p-pod and then he sent it later a
different a totally different month and
said but but
like he would just accompany it with
text I guess
Mamma Mia
um this is when Oliver was talking about
taking a Twitter break Trent is like
what why it hurts I'm very worried
um just basically like guilting Oliver
into staying on Twitter and talking to
him I assume
he says she's uh they said uh
I'm taking a break
and some friends not uh he said well why
not yeah I
I just thought it wouldn't hurt to take
a little break from Twitter that's a
good idea I think it's good for anyone
to do
and he said it hurts and then they said
question mark not leaving for long or
anything it's just a small break and
then he said I know but not having you
tweet is like not having leap of faith
taking over for you
I'm very worried
yes
why because your tweets are fun
out
and then um this is Oliver said that
Trent would never want them to go to
sleep so these are
messages of Oliver trying to go to sleep
are you uh let's see I'm back now but
I'm going to sleep good night oh really
yes good night no
it's getting late my sleep medicine's
about to make me fall asleep good night
Trent and Trent says stop taking meds
then LOL no don't leave me how old is he
at the time
in his 30s in his 30s yeah
she's enabling so many weirdos but her
success her proximity oh these kids yeah
because like her brother and then also
her bestie
they're the access they're getting to
kids is nuts
oh Adam said
Ethan I dm'd you a clip of Trent
performing on stage with Colleen he did
go to some shows wow well yeah he
clearly did because he said come meet me
at the orange yeah the orange show here
let me see if this is Worth showing or
not
I sent that link about uh Colleen's
father
yeah I mean I I yeah it's fine thank you
Adam
yeah and again I want I just want to I'm
just showing this because it's funny
I mean my dad's done embarrassing
on the internet okay and we've talked
about all of it
but this one is pretty funny it's pretty
good tell him Ballinger's dad has a
feeder fetish and he made a playlist he
doesn't realize is public
[Music]
this is good I'm sorry golden want so
here's Tim Ballinger
he has a playlist want with 78 videos
that he's made it's his place the title
at once yes
and then look at what the
helium belly inflation Valentine's Day
special obsessed forced belly inflation
I don't know what that means
I think it's like you you pump your body
up
to inflate with what how do they inflate
it with what
I don't know okay well I could watch his
playlist figure it out
it's gone
yeah I think he figured it out
Mentos blood that's awesome Mentos blood
again again
oh
I wonder is that Mentos and Coke yeah
that yeah it has a reaction well so this
ouch it's pretty I mean you learned
something new every day on the internet
they determined it was his account
because there was some old childhood
videos on there that weren't posted
anywhere else oh my God you can't hide
on the internet boy you cannot hide
they will find your inflation fetish one
playlist called want is so like
well he was typing with one hand
thank God there wasn't a need playlist
must have
[Laughter]
um yeah so at least they were all adults
agree with that's frankly he didn't do
anything wrong that's frankly the least
disturbing thing you've shown us so far
it's just funny he didn't do anything
wrong it's fine you know it's
embarrassing but it's embarrassing it's
funny he's he's you know I mean I want
to make that clear here yeah yeah yeah
so this next screenshot of Trent and
Oliver speaking uh Trent
says that
um it sounds like Oliver and their
friend had sex in like a a song that
they posted and then um Oliver says no
it's one of Tim's lyrics uh and Trent
says but she says she couldn't it
without you and thanked you sounds like
you two are a couple LOL
this guy's weird yep uh we're just
really good friends I'm just saying it
sounded like you guys were gay together
uh the next one he says if you're doing
South Carolina come hang out with me
um I'll probably be in a couple years
but I'll be going with my dad however
I lost my spot I'm sorry he says what
are you like in person
oh yeah
kind of similar to how I'm on the
internet with my internet friends but
but if it's with people at dance or just
kids I don't know I'm usually anxious
and Trend says with me how do you think
you'd be around me
[Music]
um if you're doing California come hang
out with me how old will you be I'd be
at least four he keeps asking how old
will you be there's a lot of houses
doesn't change no yeah her birthday is
is static
uh LA or San Diego or San Francisco
somewhere in uh Southern California and
then Trent says hey you you are cute
and there it is
dude um the next one's really bad
come on man
and there it is
uh if he can hear Oliver's normal voice
one day Oliver says yeah of course
um there's a video somewhere with my
normal voice and Trent says no I want
one from you and Oliver says she
probably knows where one is I'm not sure
and Trent says you can make one for me I
just want a special video of you how do
you hug is there a video of it
what the and the 13 year old responds
with of me hugging someone
bruh
this is Colleen's brother yeah yes so is
he like involved in her business or like
her no so just just but he he told me
yes he tours with her yeah people who
watched somebody knows who he is but he
um no I would consider it then he does
not participate
like she will say sorry like Trent likes
to be more private and I don't think
that that's true no I I don't think so
either I think I know why we don't Yeah
in our blog no I think they know he's a
pedo or pedo adjacent and they're
somewhat trying to keep him away from
yeah because they acknowledge that this
has happened right exactly yeah which is
so interesting because
um she did put out that video that was
highly requested from people about the
Trent special like I want to hear
Trent's story she put him out there and
she did she did yeah
um the next one uh Trent says you can
text me anytime will listen without
judgment
um he sent his phone number uh
and then Oliver responded hey I really
appreciate it but I don't feel like it's
appropriate for me to text you and I
don't think my mom would want me to
either
wow
mom I want a vape
nice try
I well good for Oliver who is
uh
Being the adult in the situation I guess
somehow
hey this is the last one
um Trent says I thought you were 16. I
have a problem
where is that written oh I see dude he
is dude Oliver said their age to you
like 40 times yeah
yeah it was at least six years ago so
you were ten I was probably six or seven
so I barely remember it but it was the
regular Wii and not the Wii U cool I
thought you were 16. I have a problem
I know you'll be pretty as blank but by
the time you're 18 possibly prettier I
just gotta get out of the teens as we
all do wait but he's 30. yeah
so what do you mean by that
like he's got to stop being attracted to
teenagers teenagers Zodi means
so Mama Mia that is a spicy meatball yes
so all of this stuff surfaces all of
this information is now in the public
Miranda Sings Colleen Ballinger is
beginning to lose sponsors on her
podcast
um to uh our ZocDoc and
one skin
one skin one God yep one skin said we
were made aware of this previously and
I've decided to Cease the relationship
completely this behavior is appalling
and we do not condone it and and support
in any form yeah so when the sponsors
are forced to put out a statement about
how they can donate that's game over
yeah that's pretty much Gigi that means
they're getting so much backlash by just
being associated with you yeah that they
need to like distance themselves we've
been dropped by law sponsors but I don't
think any of them I was wondering did
anyone ever make a statement about it so
not a public statement we get quietly
dropped okay yeah that's how you know
it's not that serious well I've seen I
think what I was thinking they sometimes
write emails back and they're like oh we
don't condone it oh that kind of yeah
yeah that kind of counts okay fair
enough fair enough let's just say email
yeah not like a state they don't make a
PR statement right yeah
so the weenies uh all talked to Rolling
Stone and that article came out just
before the show oh this just came out
just dropped oh my God yes
oh
we gotta look through it I guess I
linked it at the bottom right so this
just came out right now it came out this
morning yeah fans built her an internet
Empire now they're tearing it down four
former fans of Colleen Ballinger tell
Rolling Stones the same access that made
the comedian famous open the door for
interaction they describe as toxic
exploitative and hurtful
did they I wonder if they saw the text
with her brother
let's see they talk about Adam McIntyre
we know about that
we talk about uh
probably all the we just talked
about yeah it's it's uh in the
individual stories too
they give
this is a lot of backstory
about
ER talking about everything
oh okay yeah
this is the real article what we're
doing now so we're genuine so real this
is so comprehensive um this is next
so Becky tweeted out I can't believe
this went from a Twitter thread to share
with former Colleen fans to a Time
Magazine interview tomorrow that I
mostly accepted to validate myself which
is totally valid are you kidding
um but yes Time Magazine is coming out
with an article interviewing the weenies
oh man yeah
well I'm happy for them that they're
telling their story
um at the end I just included to all of
the weenies I hope that I told your
stories in the most accurate and
delicate way possible and that you
continue sharing we are all listening
love Olivia weenies never die thank you
the weenies forever literally okay that
was that was pretty stunning yeah uh you
know she's on tour actually oh yeah okay
so she's currently she's still on tour
there's a photo of her on stage the day
after things began to surface and she's
just like holding the mic like soup let
me grab it for you how long is she on
tour for it was a it was a rescheduled
show so I don't know if she's still
touring afterward it
there's people going to our shows right
now it's very very sparse I have seen
the seating charts oh my God a lot of
people toward the front I wonder if
she's like this is my last this is my
last paycheck also one uh location
tweeted and deleted that they assumed
that the shows would be canceled due to
due to the backlash whoa this is intense
wait they tweeted the the venue tweeted
and then deleted an announcement that
they were presuming the shows would be
canceled I mean people were calling the
venue right but that also means
her or her team saw that statement and
then reached out to the venue and was
like no delete it yeah oh yeah I'm
coming yeah no I'm coming
no refunds
I understand if some of y'all don't want
to come to the show you want to come but
um there's no refunds on this
well good first of all great job Olivia
well done well done thank you fantastic
everyone just PowerPoint and one that
came from the heart I mean wow wow
thank you wow we very personal I think
this might I don't think we've seen a
cancellation like this before on YouTube
have we no I think the the dynamic of
like children speaking with creators or
just creators talking to fans in general
is something that the world has not
dissected yet and or like really lived
through
so this is a very weird weird thing like
all of these kids coming to terms with
their trauma that nobody has really
experienced yet they don't know how to
deal with it people are saying exchange
Dawson level it is I think it might be
worse I think it's worse not like I'm
not saying ones but I'm saying it might
be a more thorough cancellation because
Shane's still making videos and I feel
like she was way more active in her
well in her stuff she was talking to
them that's what I was about to say what
what makes I think this worse and
granted I'm not the I'm not the the
drama Sage here so correct me if I'm
wrong but the thing Shane was canceled
for was his content
like the things that he put in his video
she's being canceled for that was
going on behind the scenes right and
which I think for a decade right
I don't think Shane was talking to fans
like that was he no there was like video
of him kissing like a young fan at a
meet and greet but there were there were
there weren't group chat leaks with
minors no yeah
Mama Mia that is bad so what do you say
I'm curious what your guy's opinion is
so the Trent trend is that his name the
brother okay that guy
in my opinion is a pedophile he's a
menace yeah it's it's bad with the weird
the weird stuff oh no
no that's about incest that's not an
appropriate Sound by right now okay
Dennis Dennis calm down we're trying to
have a serious conversation um with her
do you get that Vibe or is it more that
she is like remedial in like her
development and still sees herself as a
child you know what I mean if she was a
pedo
I think you would have seen more I I
listened it's like I like she's doing
she's doing she's saying and doing
things that are that are can easily be
construed as sexual with children and so
that inherently is bad but is it that
she is
like that or is it that she is so
remedial that she does not understand
why that I it seems more the second
option in my opinion I I didn't get the
sense that she's trying to like you know
yeah I think it's like it comes from
ignorance kind of the way that she's
communicating with them it's a
pathological yeah which doesn't excuse
it I'm just I'm curious what you all
thought I think she's take away from all
of that I think she doesn't really she
didn't realize she was a villain
maturation is stunted she also doesn't
seem to have much remorse or care for
people so it's a little bit of a uh
sociopathic uh touch with the sheltered
upbringing but
I didn't get the sense that like she was
getting sexual gratification from him
but who knows you know what I mean it's
a predatory either way yeah but I will
say like the way yeah the Comfort she
had with exploiting kids I mean says it
says it all but um
there's something going on with the
family if her brother is appearing to be
a pedo and also she's exploiting
children yeah
something going on there for sure and I
mean she's enabled her brother too and
giving him access
right it was very clear from that one
message that they
somebody in the mix is aware of his uh
predilections and was try at least
partially trying to intervene but
obviously didn't really stop him saw
that whole conversation so yeah I mean
but I I don't even want to uh
listen that dude needs to be monitored
her bro
yeah yeah
um and she is still touring and tickets
are still available
let me look at her torso yet how many
more shows she has
she's still touring yeah she's still
touring bro she shouldn't be allowed to
Bro she's like a predator dude I I mean
I don't know it's probably coming like
but he's not allowed by who who's gonna
stop her
well I don't know the copes did I don't
know
she because she didn't she like
technically sexually assault that girl
when she likes shred her legs or
whatever
uh yeah maybe and if that's a child I
mean that's automatically pedophile yeah
I mean it would be a the only
it would be it doesn't matter what her
individual venues right like who else is
making that call but them yeah yeah
exactly yeah but um
I mean that that has happened though
like in other cancellations when
comedians you know Louis CK and stuff
that were like touring you know the
venues canceled people's shows because
of the allegations that came out and
everything so I mean that is
an option for them
well let's see so what's today today's
the uh 21st so she is uh got a show in
two days let's go in Indianapolis
Chicago coming at you Chicago baby 24
let's go
let me see what's the tickets like on
this one
how much does she charge good question I
wonder if the prices change or if it's
still the same they might be a whole
discount in them
let's see
uh I don't even see a place to buy
tickets yeah what the more of this
website you can't just let it slide uh
at a venue in Ann Arbor it's 35
oh that's
that's fair
you know what I mean 35 did she
lower it I feel like that might be the
new price The Bargain Basement price
okay get tickets
I want to see how many seats are
available I want to see what's the price
I want to know everything
so this is at the Vic theater how what's
the capacity on that
oh the one I sent this is the Ann Arbor
theater uh this is the one that's in
Chicago it's called The Vic theater
holy this one's pretty big
uh 1400 is The Vic theater
I don't there's not a lot of people
coming to this this is all there is but
then if you oh this is the one that's
from Ann Arbor Michigan oh well this
one's and still not for
sure
for a month it's not happening
I mean she's she's selling tickets
that place is a 1700 capacity
uh it looks like it's probably sold
about 500 500 of those maybe maybe more
almost half maybe yeah 500.
foreign
and she still has another month to seal
the deal she's making money out there
dude this is her last paycheck
well
how much is it to get these ones 45
bucks
oh these are almost whoa wait hold on
this is sold out look at this
there's no seats left at this show this
is just sold out are you sure yeah well
it's not sold out but it's blue ones are
what's available right yeah she sold
this out pretty much
ha ha
let's go Chicago Chicago's gonna get it
crazy Miranda sings show soon
God how do you keep touring and like
just
just not talk about it honestly I feel
bad in a sense for her kids because like
she's gonna be really up now from
all this emotionally and
I know it's gonna be hard to be
president around the kids
I just
just want the kids to not suffer I agree
keep him away from Uncle Trent
oh my God
that wasn't a slapstick joke that was a
real concern
that we need to be worried about Uncle
Trent
you know it's uh
I believe it was Chris Rock that said
everybody's got that molesting uncle
everybody knows
I hate to tell you Adam he posted that
the scattered crowd is just low ticket
so I I don't know I I hate to tell you
Adam but this this is not that bad this
is pretty good
I mean that place is a similar capacity
to where we're doing our live show we
sold that out in 30 seconds so okay
but like she's not she's not the biggest
her Heyday she's not hosting the best
podcast in the world right uh she's not
funny she's not she's not awesome should
have a great hairline she doesn't uh if
she isn't uh
I could go on and on you could go on
forever but but all things considered I
I I would consider this a dub for her
she's definitely making money I just
sent you the screenshot of her on stage
the day after she got canceled
and it just gets worse every day right
she's gripping the out of that like
oh my God cheers my dude
oh my God how do you go out and do those
shows like nothing's going on
and the bits I assume are we still doing
the porn I'm sure we're still doing the
porn but she's been doing it her whole
career
all right who wants to come up and do
the poor bit with me come on the famous
porn big any girls in skirts out there
go you know the game Uncle Trent's
backstage he'd love to say hello to you
yeah
[Music]
uncle uncle Trent's doing a set in green
he comes you sit on his lap it's even
more personal stop it hell no
Uncle Trent stresses Santa I know it
ain't Christmas yet but we're taking
pictures
don't sit on Uncle Trent's lap don't do
it don't fall for it people
[Music]
what don't fall for it wow
well I'm glad we did this uh we needed
to do this the people need to know
what's going on the people have been
asking I've been asking it got too big
now I'm in the Rolling Stones article
about it yeah time it got inflated just
like uh her dad's uh
want want me Daddy want
oh my God love ya
yeah so that went really long uh I'm
sorry uh I'm just gonna say it I don't
think we're doing the bachelor today I
think we're done yeah cause we're
already three hours over right we're at
three and a half almost oh I think it's
just no it's okay I mean I mean it was
great but thank you guys all right well
done Olivia cheers we had over 50 000
people here which is awesome hey
everybody thanks for being here love to
see you can we just cheers my dudes
because this is our last normal show
before the break and we won't really
have an opportunity to talk the story is
going to be completely dead by the time
we get back can we just talk about
you don't have to cover the whole thing
I just really want to talk about the
stepson of the guy who's trapped on the
sub right now because this is the
craziest thing I've seen in a
while I mean yeah he's definitely the
best part of this team he's the by far
the best part of this okay so as you
guys know there is a consumer grade
submarine that is one of like five in
the world that takes people down to
visit the Titanic wreck which uh I
learned I didn't know this but
apparently it is a really really
deep down in the ocean like two and a
half miles down it's so deep it takes
some two and a half hours just to
descend to where the Titanic is crazy
um so obviously uh it's pretty intense
down there so five people went down
there a billionaire and two of his
guests he paid 250 000 per person 750
000 total to go down to visit the
Titanic wreckage
uh the submarine didn't come up
they don't know what's happened they
don't know where it is they don't know
if it imploded down there they don't
know if it floated to the top is
floating somewhere in the ocean they
don't know if it got caught
um any one of those options possible and
the crazy thing is like it's bolted from
the outside so even if they float it up
they'll still suffocate if nobody finds
yeah they're trapped in there like
somebody needs to let them out
well uh they're running they still
technically have oxygen until tomorrow
morning until tomorrow morning I'll uh
I'll be right back I gotta go take care
of something
are you gonna
we're gonna go to the submarine that no
one knows where it is it's gonna go
rescue those people out of that
sub bro baby holy I see he'll find
what a hero
if anyone's gonna find them
actually that reminds me I saw a meme
about that on the subreddit where is it
he's out he's gone
where is it oh no what is this
oh no I can't show this but it's sad
can you see my screen
no
don't show this Ian
look at this the is this
you see this I can't I can stand up and
go look at your screen oh you can't see
my screen no only Ian it's not that big
of a deal it's fine whatever you want to
see it okay
uh here
Dan's reading the tweet
I don't know what to I hate that I don't
like that man
all right let's move on
anyway
where did that sub meme go I swear I saw
it on the front page
yeah somebody posted this so
they were predicting the future here's
AB saving the submarine at the
[Applause]
he's gonna have to lose the the life
jacket though to reach those depths
right
so I was reading that uh three hours ago
was that they had 20 hours left of
oxygen I believe they're about 17 hours
left now 16 hours
um but apparently at 10 when it got down
to 10 hours of oxygen then that's like
pass out territory right
um
and then there was another theory that
actually never mind go ahead
no if they if they died of Suffocation
let's say they're still down there right
yeah
that the uh deceased body the gases
would you know expel out of them thus
causing the
um sub to uh explode
interesting dude it's under like a
freaking like 10 000 pounds per square
inch the farts aren't going to make the
sub explode no no I'm not saying farts
I'm just saying like I guess that's true
but um the decomposing yeah
decomposition it'll stink like you know
what's interesting if they are down
there their whole thing is going
to be preserved oh dude they're gonna be
rotting in this little time capsule
that'll be there until someone finds it
the memes that are going around about
this are pretty insane like uh one of
the passengers just had like three bean
and cheese burritos from Taco Bell oh
yeah dude when you watch the tour I mean
there's piss and it's one tiny
little bathroom and it just holds the
poop and pee yeah and I mean they're
calling it a bathroom is generous it's a
bucket it's a hole Yeah Yeah it's not in
Us in the sub yeah
yeah I think it
but my feeling based on nothing because
the submarine is really janky
is that if there was a leak that spring
the submarine would have crushed
uh under the immense pressure of the
bottom of the ocean
I feel like that's what happened because
I I the idea of them getting stuck down
there like how does that even happen you
know because it's pretty buoyant
and they have backup
measures to it's unclear if they have
any backup measures and also so a big
part of this is the guy who started this
company that does these tours is like
very
libertarian brained oh yeah he didn't
eat yeah no like I have it in the dock
he did an interview like six months ago
where he was talking about how
regulations and safety protocols all
that does is slow you down and like here
you go people yeah I'll take the sub
that's regulated thank you yes
absolutely it turns out those
regulations are there for a reason this
is the only thing that's been on my
mind like the past couple of years so
every Theory every possibility
everything I'm just like I'm my
imagination's going wild with it it's
all you've been talking about yeah two
days yeah I don't think anything's ever
captivated you as much as this no my my
prediction is that um
I can't say it was crushed or if it's
down there but it would be really
interesting in like you know 20 years
when they go find the sub that's I can't
wait to go pay for a tour duh oh my God
the movie adaptation I mean that would
be interesting right it's become such a
cultural phenomenon let's go see the
Titanic and we'll also see this one on
the way it's like a too far can we use
the 620k on that it's a turducken yeah
and then maybe another one perishes and
then you got a whole you got the hat
trick down there for real three boats
for one ticket
imagine Okay so
imagine getting in a sub and going down
to look at the last idiots that perished
in a sub to go do what you're doing
this sub's fine this sub safe
the last one that one was crazy
so anyway this happened everyone's
talking about you guys probably heard
about it but there was a really funny
wrinkle or I guess funny weird I don't
know I don't even know very funny
um is that the stepson of the
billionaire who chartered this sub
has been posting to social media
I'm trying to find it oh here I'll point
it up
it's in the section here under uh
Harding that's that's the uh yeah I got
it so here he actually isn't the
billionaire although I think he is very
wealthy as well right no he is he's the
billionaire yeah are there multiple
billionaires no this is him this is this
is the guy oh yeah all right sorry so
this is his stepson so his first post
was this Hamish my step thought is lost
in a submarine thoughts and prayers that
the rescue mission will be successful
that's fair I guess yes right
right then he continues
he's at the Blink 182 concert
looking like looking girl at the rock
show honestly looking like he's having a
good time he's throwing up Smiles he's
got his he's got his fly sneakers on
matches the shirt he's got he got the
merch he's in front of the mer he's
spending money
he goes this might be distasteful being
here but my family would want me to be
at the Blink 182 show as it's my
favorite band and music helps in
difficult times
okay it's a little distasteful but at
this point it's still like okay maybe
just don't post the photo right because
you're acknowledging it's distasteful so
just don't do it just don't post it but
okay he continues uh he's tweeting at
Travis Barker the front man of Blink 182
he says not the front man he's the
drummer okay is that the Chloe cartoon
yeah he's the one with the Kardashian
now he goes she's pregnant by the way
okay yay yay they've been trying for a
while yay uh he asked Travis Barker as a
direct tweet to him times are very sad
right now but I decided to come back to
the blink concert because it's always
cheer me up since the pop disaster tour
what is the pop disaster tourism this is
probably just the name of one of their
tours
so he
is looking to get acknowledged but Rich
step dad paid for these seeds man he
dead now dude
I just came up big time though
I mean he looks like he's by himself too
well
it's going to become clear why as this
as we continue so he so now at this
point he's trying to use his missing
stepdad for clout a little bit I'm not
mad yet this is pretty like the little
Cloud gobliny it's a lot of cloud Goblin
me but I mean it's still like oh he's so
it makes you feel better right now no
this crossed the line tagging Travis
crap across the line so then now he's
tagging Tom Delaney is that the singer
okay whatever he's the front man Tom I'm
back at the blink show tonight to
comfort me in this time of tragedy
thanks for the love that is crazy
someone said sync 182.
sync 182.
so now he's is this a multi-day show
what's going on here
uh
maybe he went back he did an outfit
change Tom I'm back at the blink ones
yeah the blink show he did an outfit
change he got on it
[Music]
okay wow
no yeah all new shoes new hat it
continues this man loved Lincoln too now
he's he's getting desperate now he
tagged everybody Blink-182 Tom Delaney
whatever his name is what's his name Tom
Delong Tom DeLong
Tom delongchlong got him
it's a compliment really Travis Barker
and Mark Hopper hoppis he's tagging
everyone yes I went to Blink 182 last
night not sorry this band has always
helped me through difficult times for
sure man for sure
did you see his Instagram handle too I
mean his Twitter handle
audioguy182.
okay he is a big he is a big fan I mean
clearly this man lives for the blink
okay so that would be funny if that's
where it ended but um
but it didn't end there so here cardi B
is chiming in okay interesting
what did cardi B have to say what the
Titan uh uh arresting her
you know like what is happening right
here I don't recall Titans ever making
this face either but okay I think this I
I just I don't know if she comments
directly on him in this clip
well go ahead and watch it I just wanted
you to to see the uh
from that submarine one of the
billionaires their stepson is at a
concert right at Blink 182 concert and
people is like
um well what is he supposed to do be sad
at the house is he supposed to go look
for himself yes you're supposed to be at
the house sad you're supposed to be
quiet yeah you should you should not be
out parted sure you should definitely be
at sat at the home waiting for news it's
like just five days dude it's not even
that long for me you're supposed to be
right next to the phone waiting to hear
any updates about me you're supposed to
be
um constantly your mom and like
isn't it sad that you a whole
billionaire and nobody gives a
about you like
like you missing and is
ready to shake dicks at concert
that's crazy I'd rather be broke I'd
rather be broke than like wait people
are saying he tweeted out the n-word
just a minute ago like just a minute ago
right now white people saw it okay we'll
look into that yeah
okay yeah there you go cardi B is adding
to the conversation and of course uh uh
why not
he's also been cruising on only fans
girls oh
no
is this all safe for work yes we blurred
it uh blur it this girl said can I DM
you pics like this
there's the Ocean Gate is covering
whatever is going on here that might be
inappropriate I don't know he said three
hours ago this is happening right now he
says you are perfect
dude can you not jerk off for just like
a few days
well your stepdad is potentially
dying or dead it's so funny that it's
not dead it's like active no like he's
exactly is dying yeah it's like he's
bleeding out also uh we missed this but
the reason I included the cardi B thing
is because he actually directly
responded to that with this cardi B we
all know your latest release are trash
but is your career this desperate for
attention now oh my God she's trying to
get clouded up from uh from the back
who are you Brian's about to build like
a whole career as a YouTuber now what
well Brian the sub guy we'll see about
that Brian the sub stepson he's gonna be
on Twitch soon for sure begging for Subs
subs for the sub guy
mama you are perfect he says please keep
my family in your prayers one hour later
she's like going he's like going back
and forth between horny posting on Main
and then uh asking for thoughts and
prayers he responded to it and also
quote tweeted it can I sit on you yes
please
he said yes please
yeah right so there was more to that I
think yeah it actually goes way worse
yeah uh oh
Brian why have you brought this scrutiny
on your so it became more of a thing
today I've seen a few people in the chat
pointing this out I actually
I I saw this happen in real time
I was looking at somebody had posted
screenshots of him at the blink concert
and just posted like LOL or something
and then the reply I clicked on the
replies to see what people were saying
and this girl she had like 200 likes at
the time was like what the this is
my stalker why am I like why is my
stalker going viral what the is
happening right now and I was like what
is this about and it sent me down this
Rabbit Hole you can open this last uh
album here so
um
this guy just posted a meme about it
being funny right and then she responded
not my stalker going viral on here for
having a billionaire stepdad
this person responded do not understand
how this guy keeps popping up he
shouldn't he shouldn't even be out of
prison yeah so I see this and I'm like
wait what is happening and the girl
who's accused him of stalking her says
right that took so much effort just to
get him sentenced it almost makes sense
now as to why it was so easy for him to
sue his way out
they continue
excuse me
I mean what didn't he do stalked and
harassed several people threatened to
shoot up and bomb several events
oh man you beg you guys better be nice
to him blink 182.
pretty sure we he was actually charged
with stalking people before he joined
EDM Twitter
she responded literally this though
death had charges prior to my situation
with him posted his own prison ID online
to try to intimidate people online
here's uh the last clown that bullied me
online I up so bad I was in
prison for years I'm not about talking
he posted a picture
of his prison ideas his prison ID
whoa
wow
that's oh dude it says it's his arrest
anniversary
he was arrested on geography
2018. congrats bro wow
what a weird coincidence that's so weird
that's so special it's a birthday happy
arrest day buddy happy arrest day so wow
interesting stuff man yeah so that was
just like
obviously
totally tangently related to the uh
Titanic thing but to me that's the most
fascinating aspect of the whole story
this guy had to open his mouth and now
everybody's scrutinizing his whole
life right and um just to uh
Circle back I went to his Twitter and uh
sure enough oh this is from today this
is from uh
uh about nine minutes ago he says quit
tripping in my hood I can say n-word
without the ER of course I'm down like
that on this set
holy
okay
cool oh my god dude you're billionaire
daddy is not going to be able to protect
you if he's suffocating on the bottom
haters when I need love and support
it goes back to that
okay so what if he what if this guy gets
all the money and he just he's staying
here hard Blink-182 to play my birthday
party right yeah he probably loosened
some screws on that you know what I
mean
wow so uh so there it is
fantastic I just I wanted to talk about
that and no one will give a in two
weeks so I had to fit that in well
that's our last show we had a great show
thank you to Olivia thank you for to all
the viewers are here for allowing me
that info
dude it was great it was a fantastic
time a perfect some would say a perfect
presentation oh wow thank you so much
and I invite all you guys to please join
us on Friday at 8pm PST for our live
show I look forward to seeing everybody
there in person it is going to be a
fantastic show a great show an amazing
show unbelievable the best show on Earth
folks the best show people
someone's saying they get chat Chet
Hank's vibes from him I feel that
they could be homies I feel like maybe
shut up blink 182. shout out
their music touches people dad
they should hire more security I think
for their next show
sorry to Dan we'll have to get you a new
chair when we come back from our Burger
that's okay it's kind of Evergreen so we
weren't able to get to it but uh we will
uh
we'll do it on the return show yes we'll
have something to do there but um yeah
we'll we'll be back on July 10th but
again Friday's our last show and it's
going to be great oh maybe one more
shout out to go to either or Reddit or
Twitter and fill out the survey
that uh it has something to do with uh
something we're doing on the live show
so it'd be helpful if y'all give your
answers yeah and it just takes a couple
minutes there's fun silly questions I
think you'll have fun uh answering them
and that would help us for tomorrow or
not tomorrow Friday Friday anyway guys
thanks for being here we love you all so
much thank you to our members love you
thank you to everybody watching Love You
full homo
foreign
and uh well I look forward to seeing you
guys on Friday evening PST
so with all that being said it's been a
great great show hasn't it folks we have
the best time out here H3 podcast
thanks everybody what a treat and a
treasure of a day
and uh we'll see you on Friday night
thank you guys
cheers my dude love ya no homo
[Music]
foreign